Guten Morgen Nino. Guten Morgen Tim.
Du hast unseren Jahrestag vergessen, heute ist genau fünf Jahre und ich hab kein Geschenk bekommen.
Lokbodenetzpolitik Nummer einhundertneunundneunzig und äh Wilinus Recht anmerkt.
Kein Geschenk bekommen.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Ja, hallo, ich beschenke dich hier seit fünf Jahren mit meiner Anwesenheit.
Ich schicke dich mit meiner Anwesenheit, mit meiner Präsenz.
Lassen wir das. Ähm.
Das war ja auch der Grund, warum wir die LMP zweihundert eigentlich morgen gemacht hätten, aber dann äh ihr kennt es, lange Drama,
Das aber ja zu einem viel besseren und glücklicheren Ende gekommen ist, denn wir haben ja jetzt mehrmals den Ausverkaufsstatus erreicht für unsere schöne Veranstaltung,
fünften elften. Wir haben den mehrmals erreicht und dann wieder äh in den Keller gegangen und geguckt, ob wir noch Stühle finden,
und haben die dann noch so mühsam reingezerrt. Erste Sitzplätze werden jetzt äh doppelt gebucht. Wir machen das jetzt einfach wie die Airlines. Nein, natürlich nicht. Ähm,
Es gibt wirklich noch so ganz winzige Restkontingente, die wir jetzt gerade noch äh äh in den in den Shop geworfen haben
und die Hütte ist jetzt voll, es wird dann einfach keine Stühle mehr geben, sollte es aber irgendwie jetzt so ein riesige Interessenwelle nochmal auf uns zukommen. Nachdem die Veranstaltung auf Netzpolitik Ork beworben wurde und bei methodisch inkorrekt
kam solche Wellen, sollte da jetzt nochmal so eine Welle kommen, dann könnten wir noch mehr äh Stühle kaufen,
Ähm, aber das müssten wir dann auch wirklich jetzt ziemlich bald wissen, wenn wir da jetzt noch irgendwie weiter aufstocken müssen. Ansonsten ist die Veranstaltung jetzt äh mit mit den wenigen Resttickets, die jetzt gerade noch im Store sind, dann wirklich auch erledigt.
Ja, so sieht's aus. Ist die Frage, wie wir das äh messen, diese Wellen ähm ihr könnt äh gegebenenfalls nochmal auf Twitter anklopfen, et cetera. Äh irgendwie müssen wir das halt spüren,
Und ja, ansonsten gehen wir weiter in den Endspurt und sehen mal zu, dass wir dann auch eine nette Veranstaltung für euch zusammengeklüppelt bekommen.
Also ich würde sagen, bevor ihr bei der Horst äh die E-Bay-Tickets für fünf neunundneunzig fünfhundertneunundneunzig Euro kauft, meldet euch nochmal bei uns.
Echt, es ist schon der Schwarzmarkt schon eröffnet.
Na, er die äh Klarheit, ich meine äh
Wir äh äußern uns da nicht zu, aber wir wissen natürlich genau, wer diese Tickets bestellt hat und es könnte natürlich natürlich ärgerlich für alle Beteiligten. Äh wenn diesen Tickets was passieren würde, insofern die fünf neunundneunzig bitte an uns,
dann können wir auch nochmal reden.
Genau, wir geben nämlich zwischenzeitlich dann nochmal Tickets für zweihundertfünfzig raus. Den Markt machen wir Platz.
Den Dänemark machen wir kaputt.
Ach so und aber genau.
Aber immerhin, das bleibt beim Termin und es bleibt beim Ort, den wir angekündigt haben, keine weiteren Überraschungen. Äh seht zu, dass ihr auch pünktlich da seid. So, ähm.
Wie machen wir, also Einlass achtzehn Uhr, ne? Früher nicht. Genau. Früher geht wirklich nicht, weil ähm.
Sollte man auch auflaufen.
Aber wenn dann äh auch wirklich achtzehn Uhr, weil der Beginn tatsächlich für neunzehn Uhr vier,
fest eingeplant ist.
Verstehe. Ich verste.
Das ist festgesetzt so.
Ja. Okay. Das da kann man wahrscheinlich nichts dran machen. Genau.
Oder sag mal ernst, du kriegst also Mathematik, kriegt man die Anzahl Leute in einer Stunde dadurch, weil du ja jetzt gerade von diesem Fußballspiel erzählt hast, wurde.
Ja, wir haben ja keine Vereinzelungsanlagen, wir haben da schon so eine Tür, da kann man einfach reingehen.
Tür ist eine Vereinzelungsanlage, ist eine hundert Jahre alte T.
Nein, das ist keine Falls. Und da kann man dann da können die Leute sozusagen selber bestimmen, wie schnell sie da durchgehen. Eine Vereinzelungsanlage ist ja äh etwas, was sozusagen den Durchfluss explizit steuern lassen kann.
Ja, wie unser äh Terrorheads Wave Scanner,
den wir da haben. Ich will jetzt einfach nicht nachts canner sagen, ne, aber ist natürlich klar, wir müssen ja gucken, was.
Ja, müssen halt sehen, äh wie wir danach den Bildmaterial auch aufkommen.
Comedy, komm mit früh, äh komme zahlreich. Ähm.
Genau und lass euch nicht von von denen das hier äh Angst machen. Das wird schon alles ganz nett. Nein. Und ich äh sehe auch zu, dass er, ich bin mir sicher, dass alle rechtzeitig äh da reinkommen können. Und dann geht's halt los, um die besten Plätze und so.
Das spielt ja auch noch eine Rolle.
Das gibt ein Horn.
Also für uns ist das ja auch alles neu und wir müssen das jetzt auch alles erstmal äh ausprobieren und unsere Erfahrungen äh sammeln,
Aber grundsätzlich finde ich ja die Idee von so Live-Podcasts super, die paar Male, die ich das bisher äh schon gemacht habe, waren immer alle sehr erfreulich.
Hat eine eine schöne Dynamik und dementsprechend freuen wir uns natürlich auch nach der Veranstaltung äh mit euch dann noch äh auf ein Bierchen äh herumzustehen. Und das Gespräch zu suchen, ne.
Genau. Dennoch Mitternacht ist da ramm Feierabend. Also Druckbetankung nach Sendungsende.
Ja wir legen euch dann auf den Bürgersteig.
Wir sollten vielleicht noch auf eine Sache hinweisen. Also bei der LMP zweihundert wird es ähm,
keine ähm für alle Personen geeignete Erhältlichkeit von Nahrungsmitteln geben,
Also wer dorthin kommt, ist gut beraten, sich darauf einzurichten, dass man dort unter Umständen einen Snack kaufen könnte.
Brezeln oder sowas.
Eine Brezel oder sowas, könnte gereicht werden. Ähm aber man wird dort nicht ein vollwertiges Mal
bekommen. Und deswegen wäre das, glaube ich, äh ganz angemessen vorher nochmal irgendwo eine Kleinigkeit zu essen, weil die Veranstaltung, wie gesagt, bis
Circa zehn gehen wird, wie im Anschluss dann unter Umständen noch an der an der Bierflasche nippen
und dann ist das wahrscheinlich immer wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht beraten, vorher Liter Olivenöl zu trinken oder irgendwas zu essen.
Genau. Ansonsten denke ich mal, sind keine genau, ansonsten.
Wird's geben, Kleinigkeiten wird's geben. Aber kein Käsefondue am Platz. Nee. Es könnte sogar passieren, dass es äh die ein oder andere äh den ein oder anderen Fanartikel geben könnte an Ort und Stelle.
Aber das sind ja nur Spekulationen.
Ersten Spekulation. Da wollen wir jetzt nicht so viel zu sagen. So, wann haben wir denn die letzte Sendung gemacht.
Die letzte Sendung äh war äh am siebten, das ist jetzt drei Wochen ähm.
Veröffentlicht achter Oktober heißt es.
Am achten Oktober feiern. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt knappe drei Wochen an ähm an Tragödie äh nachzuholen.
Ja, das ist echt eine Tragödie, das ist echt kein Spiel mehr.
Es gibt ohnehin kein Spiel, es gibt nur ein BND-Gesetz.
Oh. Ja. Oh.
Das wurde ja wie auch angekündigt, beschlossen, manchmal hat so 'ne Regierung ja überraschende
Effizienz in ihrem Handeln. Da werden Sachen äh da wird der Plan erfüllt. Der wurde gesagt, Freitag wird BND Gesetz beschlossen und dann wurde auch Freitag BND
Gesetz beschlossen. Es gab da noch ein vorsichtiges Aufbäumen,
in Protesten einmal von mehreren Organisationen am Donnerstag davor und dann nochmal eine ähm denke ich auch
nette Aktion von der Digitalcourage, die Aktivisten sind da morgens um vier aufgestanden und haben so äh Pappkameraden, Pappmännchen, Pappdemonstranten vor dem Reichstag aufgestellt,
mit den Forderungen der Leute, die sie da auf der Webseite eingegeben haben, weil eben klar war, diese Verhandlung, da sollte, glaube, oder diese Abstimmung sollte irgendwie um neun Uhr beginnen und da einen Protest um acht Uhr vor die Tür zu kriegen, mh,
vor allem uns äh auf so kurze, in so kurzer Zeit war dann eben,
Mit diesen Pappfiguren nur möglich, da hat äh Digitalcourage sich nochmal präsentiert, wie gesagt, am Vorabend waren
mehrere Organisationen, ich weiß gar nicht, wer alles da war, aber Netzpolitik Org äh
digitale Gesellschaft und so hatten dazu aufgerufen Campag war glaube ich auch dabei. Ähm, mit sehr geringer Zahl an, also Anne Roth, die auch dort war, wie es dann daraufhin, dass es offenbar nur.
Um die fünfzig tatsächliche Demonstranten waren ein großes Medieninteresse,
Aber ja, wenn du von einem von so einer gesetzlichen Maßnahme so überrumpelt wirst und so wenig Zeit hast, deine Kräfte zu konsolidieren, ähm dann stehst du eben auf einmal
so alleine mit einmal fünfzig Leuten und einmal ein paar Pappfiguren da und versuchst dich dagegen zu wehren, ne?
Ja, stehen da alle Rombe-Pappfiguren, ne? Gewisser Hinsicht.
Das war ähm wirklich bedauerlich und ähm das bei einem Gesetz, wo also,
Mal zusammengetragen irgendwie drei Sonderberichterstatter der Vereinten Nationen sagen, das ist so nicht in Ordnung. Die
OSZE sagt, das ist so nicht in Ordnung, namhafte Journalisten und Journalisten, Verbände sich dagegen setzen, Wirtschaftsvertreter sich dagegen setzen, zahllose Menschenrechtsorganisationen sagen, das könnt ihr so nicht machen und ähm,
quasi noch irgendwie einen Tag nach einer Sitzung des NSA-Untersuchungsausschutzes Ausschusses wird dann eben dieses,
Äh Gesetz beschlossen, dass einfach mal die zentralen Punkte, die zentralen Kritikpunkte an dem Handeln des Bundesnachrichtendienstes per se jetzt legalisiert
Das ist also, ne? Man darf das nicht vergessen. Der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss läuft noch. Die Kritikpunkte am Handeln des BND,
Und an der Organisation des BND werden
dort noch gesammelt, sind noch in der Sammlung befindlich, fragen, wie die Beteiligung an den Drohnenmorden sind noch nicht vernünftig geklärt.
Da gibt es schon quasi das Gesetz, die das eigentliche als eine Konsequenz aus den Snowdenenthüllungen,
verkauft und auch in dieser Form tatsächlich, das ist das synische beschlossen wird, ja? BND braucht eine Reform, ganz klar. So, hier ist sie. Wir lesen sie euch vor.
Erstens, wir machen das Abhören im Inland erstmal legal, ähm weil wir ja,
Die BCX-Klage vorliegen haben. Wir haben darüber gesprochen ähm Klaus Landefeld hatte sie vor einigen Wochen vorgestellt ähm.
Dass sich der Dezix eben gegen diese Abhörmaßnahmen des BND in Deutschland gerichtlich zur Wehr setzt, um da eine Rechtssicherheit herzustellen,
Und äh die Bundesregierung sagt, ja
habt ihr recht. Da müssen wir mal eine äh Rechtssicherheit klarstellen. Wir wir machen das einfach jetzt per Gesetz legal. Das wäre ja ärgerlich, ähm wenn das Gesetz hier gegen die Geheimdienste verstoßen würde. Insofern klären wir diesen Fall mal. Ja, haben sie gemacht, so
ähm BND bekommt jetzt einen Vollzug auch im Inland.
Genau, von Großbritannien äh lernen heißt in diesem Fall äh leider sieben lernen. Ausnahmsweise mal.
Ein weiterer Diskussionspunkt, den es ja immer gab, war diese zwanzig Prozent Regel. Wir erinnern uns an die Debatten,
wo nach aktueller Gesetzeslage dem BND erlaubt ist, zwanzig Prozent der Leitungskapazität abzuhören. Ja, das ähm und dieser Begriff, was sind die ähm zwanzig Prozent.
Wovon werden die gesehen? Ja ähm war immer die Frage, also ist es zwanzig Prozent der Leitungskapazität oder zwanzig Prozent dessen, was zu einem gegebenen Zeitpunkt da durchgeht? Wenn du jetzt eine Leitung hast, die,
Im Durchschnitt nur zwanzig Prozent ausgelastet ist, dann sagt der BND super. Äh dann nehmen wir das alles, weil das wäre zwanzig Prozent,
Natürlich werden Leitungen so dimensioniert, dass sie nicht die ganze Zeit ähm,
an der äh Kapazitätsgrenze gefahren werden, denn diese Infrastruktur wird ja von,
ökonomisch denkenden Unternehmen aufgebaut und nicht von einem Staat, der dann noch versucht, letzte Quäntchen Licht durch Kupfer zu pressen, ja? Also ähm hier,
hast du natürlich keine Vollauslastung der Kapazitäten, weil das von Leuten gedacht wird, die irgendwie,
'ne Zukunft dieses Landes im im Blick haben. Naja okay, lassen wir das. Diese Regel fällt jetzt auch, war ein großer, ein großer Streitpunkt,
Diese Ausbildungsfrage im NS Auer. Hier also auch jetzt der Vollzug. Vorher.
Also hundert Prozent sind jetzt sozusagen möglich. Das heißt nur bei Überlastung äh der Leitung wird das mehr als hundert Prozent rübergeschickt werden, dann wäre noch die Möglichkeit, dem Ganzen sich zu entziehen.
Vor allem musste der BND diesen Trick äh,
an einzelnen Leitungen anwenden. Jetzt können Internetanbieter grundsätzlich verpflichtet werden bei Bedarf gleich ihre ganzen Netze dem BND zu öffnen,
Also früher musstest du sagen, dieses Kabel, weil und so weiter hier und so. Und jetzt kannst du sagen, nee, nee, einmal alles, haben wir ja so, ne? Wie's genau wie's ja,
Wahrscheinlich auch eben beim äh Dezix geschehen ist.
Leider musste oder ein weiteres Hindernis, dass der BND hatte, war ja immer auch so diese ganze Scheiße begründen zu müssen
ja? Zumindest zwar nicht gegenüber den Anbietern, die deine angezapft werden, aber irgendwo musste sich der BND rechtfertigen und da gibt's natürlich in diesen Gesetzen eine Definition,
welcher, welche Bedingungen müssen erfüllt werden, damit du das darfst.
Und da steht jetzt also Gefahr für die innere und äußere Sicherheit der BRD.
Oder sonstige Erkenntnisse von Außen und sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutung.
Oder um die Handlungsfähigkeit der BRD zu wahren. Das reicht, ja? Also du kannst jetzt sagen so, wir müssen mal irgendwie so die Handlungsfähigkeit der BRD wahren und ähm einmal komplett äh,
dieses Netz abhören,
Alles klar, ne? Und dann äh fällt eben alles drunter, das heißt, du hast einen absoluten Freibrief gegen denn die Dinge sind so formuliert, dass du ähm da alles drunter fassen kannst, ne? Und äh der Gas bedeutet natürlich auch,
Dass sie, äh, dass es sehr schwierig wird, sich dagegen zu wenden, rechtlich oder sonstig, ja?
Also da haben sie viel gelernt äh aus den aus den rechtlichen Problemen, in denen sie jetzt stehen und wie sie diese loswerden können. Ähm.
Selbst die Sachverständigen des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages sagen direkt dass hier die äh Ermächtigungsgrundlage fehlt für eine solche Handlung
dass Teile des Gesetzes verfassungswidrig sind, denn wir haben ja hier, also ne, wir haben auf einmal den BND im Inland hundert Prozent mit einem Gummiparagraphen an der Leitung, ja? Das heißt, du hast keine Möglichkeit mehr über
irgendein
Tatbestand zu konstruieren, wo der, wo der BND überhaupt gegen dieses Gesetz verstoßen würde und du ähm realistisch dagegen rechtliche Mittel hättest, ja? Also wird sogar vom wissenschaftlichen Dienst des Bundestages direkt gesagt, so das pflicht euch sofort äh vor die Füße, ne?
Völlig egal, kennen wir ja. Ähm dann ähm äh sechs Monate Speicherungsfrist äh werden genehmigt,
und natürlich auch die Weitergabe mit Partnerdiensten. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt hier eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung über sechs Monate.
Wem wird die genehmigt? Dem BND wird genehmigt, alles abzuhören und das sechs Monate lang zu speichern. Der Meterdaten.
Naja gut, um die ging's ja schon immer.
Und dass ähm ähm,
dass legal mit anderen Diensten zu teilen ohne weitere großartigen Auflagen, denen irgendwie nennenswert wären,
Da hattest du natürlich in der Anhörung, die habe ich mir natürlich auch sehr äh angeschaut, als die Sachverständigenanhörungen zu diesem äh Gesetz im Innenausschuss war. Äh da hast du dann natürlich sofort so einen Schindler, der seit sechs Monaten,
Sechs Monate. So ein Terrorangriff wird zwei Jahre im Voraus geplant. Da wollen wir direkt zwei Jahre vor uns seine Speicherung für für all diese Daten,
Und natürlich müssen wir mit äh mit anderen äh Diensten zusammenarbeiten.
So sieht es aus. Aber das Entscheidende ist ja, wie uns dieser ganze Drops verkauft wird, ja?
Ist ja, wir machen jetzt die Kontrolle, wird eindeutig hier verbessert. Eindeutig verbessert. Wir installieren nämlich ein viertes, unabhängiges Gremium, ein unabhängiges Gremium. Ähm das entnennt dann die Bundesregierung. So irgendwie auch geil, ne?
Das ist super geil.
Kontrollieren uns einfach selbst, weil da haben wir äh wenigstens Vertrauen. Genau.
Ähm das heißt, es gibt hier weiterhin keine unabhängige Kontrollinstanz, die ein vollständiges Bild über die Aktivitäten des BND hätte und ähm,
das sagt sogar der der Schindler, also Ex-BND-Chef sagt, na ja, also das ist da könnte man vielleicht noch ein bisschen besser äh äh kontrollieren, als so wie sie das jetzt hier äh,
vorschlagen, ja? Selbst der Schindler sagt, na ja, also das sieht also können sie ruhig so machen, aber ähm.
Vorkommt.
Das ist also dieses Gesetz ist.
Mein der ist ja irgendwie Ex-Bendela und der sagt äh da könnte man noch ein bisschen mehr kontrollieren. Ist das schon so ein bisschen zauberlehrlingmäßig.
Indirekt, ich habe das jetzt ähm seine direkte wörtliche Kritik daran, habe ich gerade nicht parat, aber er, also er hat selbst er sagt ähm,
dass dass eine effektive Kontrolle so äh tatsächlich jetzt nicht
dass das kein Paradebeispiel für effektive Kontrolle ist. Ich habe das aus äh diesen diesen diesen Punkt aus einem Artikel, wo er nicht direkt zitiert ist. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, was genau seine Worte da sind. Muss ich jetzt mal auch,
sagen. Na ja, aber da so sieht das halt aus, ne? Da hast du dann irgendwie ähm namhafte Sachverständige.
Vor Ort, äh die da Kritik üben und das Ganze fliegt ihr so auf die Füße. Äh also es ist wirklich skandalös, weil es vor allem auch.
Konkret die großen Kritikpunkte, die großen rechtlichen Fragen, die jetzt durch Edwards Noten,
und den NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss. In ich weiß nicht, wie viel hundert Sitzungen, ja, äh oder über hundert Sitzungen da irgendwie herausgefurcht wurden, ja. Und äh.
Am Ende stehst du da. Das ist das Ergebnis. Das ist das, was wir dafür bekommen haben. Ein absoluter Skandal, absoluter Skandal.
Und es hat sich vor allem auch nichts nichts geändert sozusagen. Seit seit das Ding äh.
Nein, es wird einfach nur die Vergehen, es ist wirklich du, ich weiß nicht vor wie vielen Sendungen du dieses Motto der Sendung geprägt hast, das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste, das ist das, was hier passiert. Fällt dir nichts mehr zu ein.
Ja und vor allem selbst dieser ohnehin schon problematische kurze Dienstweg, den das Ganze genommen hat. Ich meine, es gibt Gesetze, die werden,
Über Jahre diskutiert und hier
wird es sozusagen schon zur Unzeit losgelassen und dann natürlich auch überhaupt nicht breit diskutiert, sondern einfach nur so unter diesem na ja, das passt schon, das müssen wir jetzt mal so machen
freue mich halt auch wirklich so wozu braucht man dann eben sozusagen so eine große Regierung mit so vielen Leuten äh in ihren äh im im Parlament unterstützenden Fraktionen,
Wenn sowas nicht breit diskutiert werden kann. Also ich frage mich auch wirklich, wie man interessiert, wie du.
Wir haben einen Untersuchungsausschuss dazu.
Ja, ja, na klar, aber trotzdem, also.
Der ist noch nicht fertig.
Der ist nicht fertig, klar, aber ganz unabhängig davon, jetzt,
Jetzt haben wir schon sozusagen dieses Problem der großen Koalition, könnte man ja mal positiv sagen, viele Leute in den Regierungsfraktionen, die äh äh sich, sagen wir mal, auch potenziell mit diesen ganzen Maßnahmen auch umfangreich beschäftigen können,
Ja, sind ja nicht nur zehn Leute, die da rumhängen, sondern ein paar hundert, die irgendwie äh keine Ahnung, was die alles so zu tun haben, aber es sollte ja wohl möglich sein, so ein wichtiges Gesetz auch mal mehr unter die Lupe zu nehmen. Aber offenbar gibt es gar keinen Widerstand
Also zumindest wird ja noch nicht mal offen debattiert oder nachgefragt. Kannst du dir wirklich vorstellen, dass die alle,
dieser einheitlichen Meinung sind, dass das eine gute Idee ist.
Ich würde mich freuen, da ähm mal mit Vertretern der Bundesregierung zu sprechen.
Also ich rede gar nicht mal von der Bundesregierung, ich rede wirklich von den Fraktionen im im Parlament.
Ja, also von den wie nennt man das Koalition, Religionsvertrag? Ähm ich habe da auch ähm einige Versuche unternommen. Bisher äh.
Da schauen wir mal alle so ein bisschen an die Decke, oder?
Ja, die haben leider irgendwie alle schon was vor.
Ja, grad äh passt jetzt gerade überhaupt nicht.
Oh schlecht. Ich gebe nicht auf.
Was machen die Leute.
Also das ganz spannende Veranstaltung, die da alle am fünften November stattfinden. Das ist.
Da haben wir uns gerade so ein so ein Wochenende ausgesucht, ne.
Wirklich ungünstig.
Wo wirklich alle gerade äh dringend in ihrem Wahlkreis gebraucht werden.
Gerade Regierungsklausur. Die Selbstverständlichkeit, dass der Gegenstand der Kontrolle vom Kontrolleur und nicht vom zu kontrollierenden bestimmt wird, ist bislang wenig ausgeprägt, war die tatsächliche Kritik äh von äh Schindler,
Ja? Also der hat äh der sagt die große Koalition fördere eine weitere Zersplitterung der Kontrolle. Also selbst er sagt es nicht nur ein bisschen, sondern sehr scharf. Das ist wirklich äh krass. Das hat der ähm,
Das ist also Teil seiner Stellungnahme an den Innenausschuss, äh in dem er da eben war. Ja, also das, wie gesagt, Schindler, Him Self, ja.
Sagt, das geht nun echt nicht. Untaugliches Prinzip ist da der Begriff.
Also entweder ist er ich will sie nicht über überspitzen, aber so man könnte ja jetzt sagen so oh wird ja jetzt im Ruhestand zum Lamm oder äh oder sind's oder sind seine Nachfolger einfach noch krasser drauf.
Das ist der Mann, der gleichzeitig in der gleichen Stellungnahme äh sagt, er hätte gerne zwei Jahre äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung für die Geheimdienste, ne,
Also der der sagt dir so, dein Kontrollsystem Olum, willst du mich verarschen, ne? Also das muss.
Aus Bild BD Perspektive ein totaler Soft, die wolltet wurde Zeit das den man geht. Zwei Jahre vor Astatenspeicherung. Ja, das dann wird das überhaupt noch gelöscht wird.
Ja, lächerlich, was willst du denn damit? Ja. Weißt du, wie lange es Terrorismus gibt? Tausende von Jahren. Tausende von Jahren gibt's Terroristen. Wir machen heute noch ein bisschen weiter mit äh ähm dem äh dem NSA. Ja. Ähm.
Ja, da war ja dann auch noch ein bisschen äh Diskus.
War jetzt wieder eine Anhörung ähm auch wieder schön in bei unseren Freunden der technischen Aufklärung aufgearbeitet ähm.
Da war jetzt eine junge Dame von der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten vor Ort. Also
die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte ist ja auch eine Behörde und ähm die Gabriele Löwenau ist ähm im Stab dieser Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten für die Geheimdienste,
zuständig und ähm da war dann die sehr skurrile Situation, dass es ja den Bericht der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftrag.
Ähm auf Nutzpolitik Org schon zu lesen gibt, der ist aber weiterhin geheim,
Deswegen darf da im NS Auer in der öffentlichen Sitzung zumindest nicht drüber gesprochen werden. Oder über die Inhalte nicht. Ähm die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hatte auch versucht, den Bericht herunterstufen zu lassen,
um ihn öffentlicher zu machen. Das Kanzleramt hatte das aber mit Verweis auf die enthaltenen BND Sachverhalte abgelehnt.
Und äh deswegen hattest du jetzt also diese skurrile Situation ähm dass du, dass dieses, dass jeder weiß, was in diesem Bericht drinsteht, jeder die achtzehn äh Kritikpunkte kennt, die wir hier auch schon behandelt hatten. Ähm,
Aber äh sieht dort eben nicht so wirklich darauf ähm.
Eingehen darf. Ähm und der entscheidende Punkt oder das entscheidende Zitat der Frau Löwenau ist, dass sie sagt, wir haben nur die Möglichkeit zu berichten und zu beanstanden,
Wenn wir geprüft haben, monieren wir das Ergebnis, wird dann dementsprechenden Ressort des Kanzleramtes äh zugesendet.
Und sie haben dann die Möglichkeit, dazu Stellung zu nehmen.
Das ist aber dann das Ende. Sie sagt dann, diese Stellungnahme, dieser Diskurs äh ist umfangreich, verlaufen etwas umfangreicher, sagt sie dann etwas zufrieden. Und es gab auch schon mal einen Dissens,
Ähm aber ohnehin sein, darüber hinaus der äh Datenschutzbehörde die Hände gebunden. Sie kann jetzt nichts weiter mal machen,
Also sie hat jetzt gesagt, hier ist unser geheimer Bericht. Dann haben sie darüber diskutiert, dann waren sie darüber nicht einstimmig. Dann wurde vom äh Bundeskanzleramt gesagt, das Ding bleibt geheim.
Und äh Thema erledigt.
So, dass so viel zu der, zu der, zu dem Handeln und eben leider auch der Handlungsmöglichkeiten der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten in dieser Angelegenheit.
Ja, kann man sich auch in etwa vorstellen, wie das so mit der Kontrollkommission und so weiter ähnlich abläuft. Also im Prinzip haben wir,
Ein System, in dem ausschließlich beklagt werden kann, wenn überhaupt, wenn man überhaupt genug Daten äh erhält, um mal ordentlich was beklagen zu können. Und dann wird so beklagt und dann steht man so rum.
Und dann danke für ihre Klage. Wir machen dann mal weiter, als wäre nichts geschehen.
Ja, ist also es ist äh na, das tut dieser diese Arroganz, dieses vollständige Ignorieren von allen möglichen Gesetz
Ebenen und Institutionen, die wir in diesem Land haben, um irgendwo eine Kontrolle und ein Gleichgewicht herbeizuführen. Das strotzt hier
aus allen Ecken und Enden dieser ähm,
Dieser Bundesregierung, denn kommen wir nochmal zu einem weiteren Punkt, eine ein Thema, was ja schon vollständig aus den Augen verloren wurde, ist das ja ähm,
so ein Edward Snowden da sitzt der,
ähm der diesen ganzen Skandal ins Rollen gebracht hat und der relativ viel darüber weiß. Und dass einer der großen Streitpunkte oder einer der großen Kritikpunkte.
Natürlich auch die Zusammenarbeit der Geheimdienste ist, ja. Und ähm da gibt es ja immer noch die Bestrebung, das Bestreben der kleinen ähm,
Oppositionsgruppen, dass sie doch ganz gerne die diesen Menschen, der diesen ganzen Skandal ins Rollen gebracht hat, doch mal als Zeugen,
in ihrem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, aber äh wir sehen, dass der die Vernebungsphase dieses Ausführungsschuss ja ohnehin dem dem Ende zuneigt. Das wäre also jetzt inzwischen
wirklich sehr amüsant oder absolut unrealistisch, dass es Noten dann nochmal geladen wird,
Aber Martina Renner äh von der Linken hat nochmals bei der äh Bundesregierung nachgefragt, ähm was sie denn überhaupt unternommen habe, um herauszufinden, was Norden in den USA konkret vorgeworfen wird. Ähm.
Weil davon ja auch die Frage abhängt, ob Deutschland rechtlich in der Lage wäre, Snowden Asyl zu bieten,
ne, oder ob Deutschland vielleicht nach eigener Gesetzgebung verpflichtet wäre oder sich selber die Pflicht die Pflicht auferlegt hätte, Snowden auszuliefern,
Ähm und dann ähm gibt also das Justizministerium ähm bekannt in dem Moment die Bundesregierung.
Die Bundesregierung gibt bekannt, ähm ja, das amerikanische Justizministerium hat uns gesagt, welche,
Vorwürfe gegen das Norden vorliegen.
Aber das amerikanische Justizministerium hat uns mitgeteilt, eine Herausgabe des Schreibens nicht äh zuzustimmen,
Dies wird damit begründet, dass ein Teil der in dem Schreiben enthaltenen Informationen durch das zuständige Gericht als vertraulich eingestuft worden seien und daher
nur für die Zwecke der Festnahme und Auslieferung von Edwards Nohnverwendung finden dürfen. Das heißt, die Bundesregierung weiß,
was gegen den vorliegt? Das könnte klare relevante Folgen haben dafür,
für die Frage ob und inwiefern der gute Mann vielleicht Asyl in Deutschland bekommen könnte.
Aber da kann man nicht sagen, kann man nicht sagen, ne. Das würde ja dann wahrscheinlich einen unfairen äh Wettbewerbs äh Vorteil für Edward Snowdens Anwälte geben, wenn die wüssten, was überhaupt diesen Menschen vorgeworfen wird.
Also man merkt, man merkt auf jeden Fall, sie wehren sich mit Händen und Füßen und es gibt überhaupt auch nicht nur das geringste Interesse äh da dran, ihn in dieses Land zu lassen. Das kann man, glaube ich, jetzt mal äh abschließend äh festhalten und äh ich freue mich halt immer wieder, was,
die ähm was eigentlich die wirklich entscheidenden Kräfte sind, die die diese Position aufrechterhalten.
Was würdest du meinen.
Entschuldigung, ich habe die Frage äh nicht gepasst.
Was ich meine, dieser Widerstand ist ja offensichtlich. Ich frage mich nur, was sind die primären Kräfte, die diesen Widerstand aufrechterhalten.
Ja, das sind natürlich halt die äh Echsenmenschen mit ihren Chemtrails in Zusammenarbeit mit der linken Weltverschwörung,
Das Judentum ist da am Ende natürlich klar unter Kontrolle,
Ich weiß es nicht. Es es stinkt aber bis zum Himmel und man muss sich, wenn man so eine Politik macht, ja, muss man sich und da bin ich jetzt mal wirklich,
bitter und ernst, wenn du so Politik machst, musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn irgendwann ähm,
solche Leute auf der Straße stehen, wie wir sie bei der bei der AfD sehen, äh wie wir gerade Donald Trump sehen und Menschen sagen, Fak
gehen uns am Arsch vorbei, ihr seid Lügner und wir wollen euch loswerden. Ist uns völlig egal, wie viel Dreck ihr am Stecken habt. Genau diese Bewegungen in der Gesellschaft, die förderst du damit,
Wenn du so einen Scheiß machst, wo wo es nur noch ganz klar ist, dass, weißt du, du hast diese ganzen Sachverständigen da und jeder sieht, jeder weiß, dass du da Scheiße baust.
Und dann musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn irgendwann die politische Opposition ähm keine Lust mehr hat, sich mit dir auseinanderzusetzen, sondern sagt alles klar, Sturm.
Ihr könnt jetzt sagen, was ihr wollt. Wer einmal lügt, dem glaubt man nicht und wenn er auch die Wahrheit spricht und jetzt machen wir hier mal Politik ohne Fakten,
Dann wollen wir mal gucken, was am Ende stehen bleibt. Das ist genau das, was du gerade siehst und diese Bewegung, dass sie so viel aufwind erfahren sich als ganz stark das Verschulden äh einer derartigen Politik.
Also, ich würde nicht so weit gehen zu sagen, das ist der einzige Grund, aber es ist definitiv etwas, was äh wie sagt man so schön ins Nordherping. Also es ist wirklich so ein,
es ist wirklich man,
Man nimmt sozusagen diesem Argument, man sei ja eine offene transparente äh Gesellschaft, einfach jeden Wind aus den Segeln und ähm,
macht sich angreifbar,
Macht sich extrem angreifbar und da muss man sich, glaube ich, wirklich nicht wundern, wenn man dann irgendwann selbst wenn man mal richtige Argumente auf der äh auf seiner Seite hat, seine Rosa, ja, Argumente,
Argumente ist so, zwanzigstes Jahrhundert. Äh wir machen jetzt hier was anderes.
Du machst so eine äh Hütchenspielpolitik mit einem BND-Gesetz. Ja und beklagst dich dann äh, dass ein dass ein Trump irgendwie sagt, was weiß ich, ich sehe senke die Unternehmenssteuern und dadurch werden die Armen reich,
Ja? Dann kannst du natürlich sagen, das ist aber Unsinn, was du sagst. Und dann, also ne, okay, wir wir wissen, wo der,
Weg hingeht, aber natürlich um jetzt mal realistisch.
Tische geht.
Realistisch da oder die Antwort ist natürlich, die haben direkt am Stecken bis oben und versuchen jetzt irgendwie ähm.
Eine eine Taktik des Aussitzens und dann so nach jetzt, was ist das jetzt? Zwei, drei Jahre, ist Norden. Da kann man dann auch einfach mal drüber schütten.
Sie bauen eine Informationsmauer auf und wir müssen dafür bezahlen.
Kommen wir mal, äh wir haben uns jetzt lange genug über Deutschland aufgeregt, legen, regen wir uns mal über UK auf. In in UK ist jetzt wirklich auch was. Äh, also was passiert da? Da war auch ein ein kurzer Knick in der Matrix,
Ähm das Investigatory Power Stribionöl,
wir wissen, dass äh quasi Geheimgericht im Raum der Geheimdienste, vor dem sich die Geheimdienste verantworten müssen.
Hat jetzt,
irgendwie so gesagt, hey, wir haben hier ein Urteil gefällt und alle müssen, ja, ja, Cambis, alles in Ordnung, ne äh sagt das heimliche, massenhafte Sammeln und Auswerten von Verbindungs- und Standortdaten durch MI five MI Six und,
GCAQ. Seit der Auflage des Überwachungsprogrammes im März neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig. Also seit achtzehn Jahren.
Verstößt gegen das in Europa verbriefte Recht auf Achtung des Privatlebens. Und alle so what's the fuck.
Also irgendeiner hat nicht aufgepasst, der Zensor war pinkeln. Du hast jetzt auf einmal von dem Investition Power Street gesagt, bekommen ähm,
Es ist äh das, was ihr da achtzehn Jahre lang gemacht haben, verstehst gegen
Artikel acht der EU. Menschenrechtskonvention, nämlich das Recht auf Achtung des Privat- und Familienlebens. Ich darf zitieren, erstens, jede Person hat das Recht auf Achtung ihres Privat- und Familienlebens, ihrer Wohnung und ihrer Korrespondenz?
Man könnte argumieren mentieren, dass ihre Korrespondenz ja hier,
über achtzehn Jahre sehr geachtet wurde. Es wurde alles beachtet von mehreren Geheimdiensten gleichzeitig, aber das ist hier nicht gemeint. Zweitens, eine Behörde darf
Ausübung ihres darf in die Ausübung dieses Rechts nur eingreifen, soweit der Eingriff gesetzlich vorgesehen
und in einer demokratischen Gesellschaft notwendig ist für die nationale und öffentliche Sicherheit, für das wirtschaftliche Wohl des Landes zur Aufrechterhaltung der Ordnung, zur Verhütung von Straftaten, zum Gesetz der Gesundheit oder der Moral,
der Rechte und Freiheiten anderer.
Schutz der Gesundheit.
Das Problem ist
Wir haben jetzt hier schön ein ein öffentliches Eingeständnis, das achtzehn Jahre Illegal war, ähm, aber die Betroffenen wurden darüber nicht informiert, weil sie darüber nicht informiert wurden, steht Ihnen auch kein,
sinnvoller Rechtsweg zur Verfügung. Das heißt, äh das wird jetzt hier äh auch äh größtenteils ohne weitere Folgen bleiben, aber.
Ja, das Problem wird.
Dass wir darüber gesprochen haben.
Ja, das Problem wird sich ja dann ohnehin äh demnächst erledigen, weil wenn das in Europa äh ein verbrieftes Recht ist, dass man nicht privat äh Sphäre zu achten hat,
Dann hat das Herr jetzt für die Vereinigten, für das Vereinigte Königreich keine benennenswerten Konsequenzen, da sie sich ja einfach das Europas entledigt werden.
Also das Gesetz verstößt hier gegen die Geheimdienste, aber Abhilfe ist eh schon auf dem Weg. Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Ja, ja, das ist sozusagen das Problem löst sich von ganz alleine.
Ja. Ja, ein weiterer Grund.
Das ist eh ein Problem, zumal's ja äh weiß nicht, ob du das weißt, aber es gibt ja in diesem Land keine Verfassung.
Das hast du mehrfach betont.
Ja
Das äh soll sozusagen das das gesamte äh Recht basiert quasi nur auf Präzedenzfällen und und wie sich das so bisher hergeleitet hat und äh dementsprechend gibt's nichts, worauf man sich da in irgendeiner Form berufen kann. Da sind wir dann halt in so einer Luxussituation in gewisser Hinsicht. Äh auch wenn wir viel zu klagen haben, dass äh
ist mit der Ist-Situation in Großbritannien gar nicht zu vergleichen. Tja, so sind sie.
Ja, wunderbar. Wir haben ja noch ein weiteres, spannendes Urteil, deswegen müssen wir da jetzt mal ähm.
Genau, gucken wir mal auf Europa.
Also da muss ich mal sagen, diesen Fall, äh man muss ja auch echt mal also Ingo Dachwitz, ne? Autor oder Redakteur bei Netzwerk Tick Ork hat diesen Fall irgendwie in einer Weise äh verfolgt und erklärt, das war wirklich vorbildlich, muss man echt einfach mal
loben und zwar die Frage um die es geht. Ähm ist.
Sünd, sind dynamische IP-Adressen von Internetnutzern, personenbezogene Daten. Ähm relativ äh wichtige Frage, weil personenbezogene Daten unterliegen ja dann Datenschutz.
Und wenn du, wenn personenbezogene, wenn diese Daten ähm dem Datenschutz unterliegen, dann dürfen sie ähm ohne äh Einwilligung nicht gespeichert werden.
Also dynamische IP-Adresse muss man dazu sagen, sind sozusagen die Adressen, die meinen Computer oder mein Rauter
zugewiesen bekommen zum Zeitpunkt einer neuen Verbindung, das kann sich dann halt so im Tages- oder Wochen oder Monatsabstand immer mal wieder ändern, das heißt man hat nicht halt eine, sondern man hat halt immer mal wieder eine andere. Deswegen ist das ganze System
dynamisch.
Also üblicherweise, wenn du jetzt einen Server irgendwo mit fester Internetverbindung hast, dann hat er eine statische IP-Adresse, äh die ist zugewiesen, die hat ja seinen äh seinen Vertragslaufzeit lang und ähm,
deine Fritzbox zu Hause hat ja tatsächlich eine
'ne Zwangstrennung oder macht die automatisch einmal pro einmal in vierundzwanzig Stunden und kriegt pro Verbindung üblicherweise würde ich jetzt sagen alle vierundzwanzig Stunden eine neue IP-Adresse,
Was zur Folge hat, dass äh äh,
beispielsweise nun ähm nicht ohne Weiteres von dem Server Meterebene Punkt ME festgestellt werden kann ähm wann,
Du als Person, Lockbuchnespolitik heruntergeladen hast, ja? Also es wird, es ist nicht so nicht unmittelbar rückführbar.
Ähm aber ähm natürlich,
relativ einfach Rückführ war, weil die Provider äh diesen äh diese Zuordnung ja durchaus im Rahmen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Abrechnungsspeicherung äh für einige Zeit.
Aufrechterhalt äh äh aufbewahren, ne? Da gab's diese Speicherfristendebatte äh alte Geschichte hier auch öfter schon behandelt im Rahmen des IT-Sicherheitsgesetzes nochmal angesprochen und so weiter. Diese Frage ist durchaus relevant. Ja, sehr relevant.
Und ähm im deutschen Telemediengesetz steht eben drin, Speicherung, personenbezogener Daten nur nach Einwilligung. Und äh Patrick Breyer ähm,
langjähriger Datenschutzaktivist in vielen verschiedenen Kontexten. Im Moment bekannt als äh Fraktionsvorsitzender der Schleswig-Holsteinischen ähm,
Piratenpartei hat schon zweitausendsieben,
gegen das Bundesjustizministerium geklagt, dass es beim Besuch dieser deren Website, dessen Webseite,
die IP nicht speichern dürfe. Und er war damit erfolgreich vor dem Landgericht Berlin.
Da hat er gesagt, ah ähm dann möchte ich das für alle Bundes äh für alle anderen bitte auch und äh klage direkt in die gesamte Bundesregierung,
Ja, dann hat der das Landgericht Berlin aber dem,
dem zuständigen Bundesinnenministerium Recht gegeben, mit der Argumentation die IP-Adressen müssten für die Sicherheit und Funktionsfähigkeit der Seite gespeichert werden.
Übrigens das gleiche Argument, das dann auch angebracht wurde ähm äh beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, wo ja auch das Zele-Mediengesetz entsprechend erweitert wurde und dass die Speicher äh Rechte äh ausgeweitet wurden.
Ähm, dann ist der Patrick Breyer vor den Bundesgerichtshof gezogen.
Der hat gesagt, oh, interessante Frage, wir werfen das Ganze mal zum EuGH.
Und gucken, was der EuGH zu diesen Fragen entscheidet. Frage sind dynamische IP-Adressen, Personenbezogenen bezogen Daten und wenn ja, was ist die Konsequenz, für deren Speicherung durch Webseitenbetreiber?
Auch wieder so 'ne, so 'ne, so 'ne Eskalation nach Europa, wie wir das bei Max Schrems auch schon gehabt haben, man kann halt den Weg nicht direkt dahin suchen, aber wenn sich das sozusagen
bei den Gerichten so darstellt, dass das ein unter Umständen nur auf europäisch Ebene zu lösen. Das Problem ist, dann findet das statt und sowas auch hier.
Jetzt haben wir äh die Situation ist zweitausendvierzehn wurden von deutschen Behörden im Schnitt alle fünf Sekunden Bestandsdatenauskunfts,
Aufträge erteilt oder Anfragen erteilt.
Alle fünf Sekunden.
Alle fünf Sekunden. Und ähm,
Wir erinnern uns auch, das ist damals unter schwarz-gelb schon, wurde entschieden, dass IP-Adressen zu diesen Bestandsdaten gehören. Was äh schon damals ein absoluter.
Absolut crazy Idee war, weil sie sind ja nun mal dynamisch
ja? Und Bestandsdaten sind statische Daten, da gehört sowas zu wie ähm wo wohnst du äh ne, weil wie alt bist du, wie heißt du
Wo ist der Anschluss? Das sind Bestandsdaten. Und ähm es gab aber diese Änderung, nach der gesagt wurde, na ja und wann du, welche IP-Adresse hattest, gehört jetzt auch zu den Bestandsdaten. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. Ab geht's.
Das spielt natürlich dann auch eine Rolle für die für die für das Urteil oder die Argumentation vor dem EuGH mit dieser Frage, weil wenn jeder.
So wie er will, diese diese Zuordnung zwischen dynamischer IP-Adresse und Name äh und Anschlussinhaber,
durchführen kann ohne weitere Hürden und bei alle fünf Sekunden eine Anfrage kann man da sagen, da gibt's keine weiteren Hürden,
Na das natürlich auch Konsequenzen für das, was eine dynamische IP-Adresse bedeutet. Gleichzeitig muss man aber sagen, du machst dir irgendwie ein äh wenn du dir einen Debian installierst und machst einen Webserver an
Pedifol schreibt das die IPA, das sind die Lokfiles bis Anne Dunnemals, ne? Also da da müsstest du
Es ist schon wirklich tatsächlich einfach mal gängige Praxis, dass eine die Fortkonfiguration eines Webservers jeden Rick festlockt und in diesem Request auch die IP-Adresse mitschreibt.
Ja, das ist absolut norm.
Das ist normal. Ähm schauen wir uns mal die Argumentation an.
Also zumindest zu einem bestimmten, für einen bestimmten Zeitraum, also typischerweise werden ja auch diese Lokfights nicht wissen, alle Ewigkeit vorgehalten, sondern irgendwann mal äh wegrotiert, aber das kann natürlich auch in Back Backups landen, et cetera, weiß man nicht
von daher.
Es ist in der Tat ähm also ich will da jetzt nicht auf jede einzelne Linusdistro eingehen, aber so,
per die schreiben, die das, glaube ich, einfach weg und zippen das Lock-Road-Tade, Sipped, Sip, das irgendwann mal, aber in den Defold Conflix siehst du selten, dass da einer sagt, das ist jetzt mehr als so ein so viele Monate alt, das werde ich weg. Ist übrigens tatsächlich auch ein ähm,
ein Problem
für Betreiber größerer Infrastrukturen, dass die unter Umständen natürlich äh diese Lokfils auch wirklich äh nicht so lange aufbewahren müssen, dürfen, ne,
Es gibt's ja auch, es gibt auch Höhen, Höchstspeichergrenzen und die, die sich dann überlegen müssen, wie sie ihre Lokfights irgendwie wegwegsen oder so. Lassen wir das.
Server hat ja dafür auch schon mal ein Big Brother Award bekommen. Dafür, dass die die Volleinstellung so ist.
Äh so ähm.
Interessant ist das Ganze natürlich für Tracking, weil wenn diese IP-Adressenzuordnung Teil der Bestandsdatenauskunft werden, dann kannst du eben auch
hast du die gleiche Situation, die du hättest bei einer statischen IP-Adresse, die du über alle möglichen Kontinente tracken kannst? Wenn du dann äh dir überlegst, wie die ähm Behörden, die solche Ausbraten, Anfragen mit den Geheimdiensten kooperieren, dann weißt du, was das
was diese Konsequenz bedeutet. Dann diese Argumentation.
Für die Sicherheit solche Sachen zu speichern, das habe ich damals ausführlich, als Sachverständiger im Innenausschuss zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz gesagt. Hier ist er, pass mal auf,
so ein IT-Sicherheitsvorfall ist eine akute Angelegenheit und du willst den akut lösen.
Und es ist insbesondere wurde da auch argumentiert. Für die Behebung von Störungen, da wurde nicht argumentiert für die Aufklärung, ne? Also das Argument, was der Schindler jetzt anbringt, wo er sagt, ähm,
Terror ist tausend Jahre alt, deswegen müssen wir solange die Daten für die Aufklärung speichern. Das wurde beim IT-Sicherheitsgesetz nicht gemacht. Hier geht es rein um die Argumentation Sicherheit,
und da äh wird argumentiert für die Sicherheit im Rahmen der IT-Sicherheit wollen wir IT äh wollen wir die IP-Adressen dieser Requests speichern. Und ich kann nur sagen,
absolut richtig. Du möchtest wissen, welcher Rickfest von von wo kam
Um zum Beispiel zu erkennen, ob eine IP-Adresse bei dir gerade irgendwie Theater macht. Ja, wenn du von jemandem den fünf, von einer bestimmten IP-Adresse, den fünften Feld Login hast,
dann möchtest du unter Umständen sagen oder der ganz der fünfte Feldlog innerhalb einer Sekunde dann möchtest du sagen ja das der versucht hier gerade einen Blutforce Angriff mit dem rede ich nicht mehr. Ja? Du möchtest da,
Auf Basis der Herkunft von Reques durchaus,
Akute Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen können. Und da hilft es dir sicherlich auch, diese diese IP-Adressen mal für einen Tag oder zwei oder sieben,
vorhalten zu können, um bestimmte Muster zu erkennen.
Sozusagen eine private Vorratsdatenspeicherung mit begrenztem Zeitraum.
Akut mit stark begrenzten Zeitraum. Wir reden aber jetzt hier von sechs Monaten.
Und das ist nun wirklich für akute IT-Sicherheitsmaßnahmen.
Ein bisschen üppig.
Bisschen üppig, ja? Also,
Ne, als jemand, der durchaus mit dem Verteidigen von IT-Infrastrukturen täglich beschäftigt ist, ähm kann ich auch ganz klar sagen, meine äh meine Serverloggen für kurze Zeit, IP-Adressen,
um eben Muster zu erkennen und aufgrund dieser Muster unter Umständen eben Gegenmaßnahmen einzuleiten.
Aber sechs Monate,
Für die IT-Sicherheit ist einfach Quatsch, das ist einfach Kappes, ja? Nach sechs Monaten ist es nämlich scheißegal, wenn du, selbst wenn du, wenn jetzt jemand bei auf deinem Server Daten rausträgt, ja,
Und du siehst dann, du kannst dann sehen, ah, Shit vor, vor sechs Monaten wurden mir Daten rausgetragen, die sind jetzt, was weiß ich, auf,
Ähm jetzt will ich mal gucken, mit welcher IP das geschehen ist. Dann ist das keine Frage der IT-Sicherheit mehr. Der Schaden ist geschehen,
Dann noch eine Frage der Strafverfolgung oder sonst was, ja? Ähm und dann kannst du halt wissen, von welcher Torexit-Note der Angriff kam,
Aktivisten die Tür eingetreten und der Computer weggenommen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch. So, also dafür brauchst du das nicht zu machen,
kommen wir zum Urteil.
Genau, was haben sie denn nun? Urteil. Beschlossen.
Urteil des des EuGH lautet IP-Adressen sind Personen Daten ähm,
und können dem Datenschutzrecht unterliegen, wenn der Seitenbetreiber über rechtliche Mittel verfügt, die es ihm erlauben, den Nutzer anhand der Zusatzinformation über die dessen Internetzugangsanbieter verfügt, bestimmen zu lassen,
Also wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, zu einem äh zum Internetprovider zu gehen und zu sagen, ey, wer war das? Und der antwortet dir, dann sind das Personenbezogene Daten.
Aber auf welcher Seitenbetreiber hat diese Möglichkeit?
Da ist eben die Frage, wer wer diese Möglichkeit hat. Es geht nämlich noch weiter. Der Entscheidung sagen erstmal, das können Personen bezwungene Daten sein. Jetzt sagen sie aber, ein Teil des deutschen Telemediengesetzes ist ungültig.
In dem nämlich gesagt wird diese Daten,
und andere Personen gedachten ähm können außer zu Abrechnungszwecken nur nach Einwilligung der Nutzer gespeichert werden,
denn die europäische Datenschutzrichtlinie,
Wir wissen diejenige, die gerade eigentlich überarbeitet wird, wo ähm insbesondere Jan Philipp Albrecht und seine Mitarbeiter.
Ähm Ralf Benrath ist hier ja noch hervorzuheben. Wir kennen den Film, die da gerade dran arbeiten, aber deren Vorgänger,
ähm sieht in Artikel sieben vor, dass es für das Speichern und Verarbeiten personenbezogener Daten eine Abwägung zwischen den berechtigten Interesse eines Diensteanbieters
und den Grundfreiheiten und Rechten eines Nutzers geben muss.
Dieser Grundsatz sei durch das deutsche TMG zu stark ähm eingeschränkt. Und jetzt sagt, sagen sie, ähm.
Durch den Cyber ähm besteht ein berechtigtes Interesse der Dienste, Anbieter, IP-Adressen zu speichern.
Also genau das, wo wo ich gerade schon gesagt habe, ist Kappes.
Aber deshalb ist da draußen und der ist ein berechtigtes Interesse und deswegen darfst du loggen, auch wenn das Personenbezogene Daten sind und außerdem könnt ihr euch direkt mal euer Telemediengesetz ähm killen, weil äh da ist dieser Grundsatz nicht ausreichend drin gewürdigt.
Mit dieser Antwort.
Passung an die Realität.
Mit dieser ähm.
Mit dieser Antwort geht das Ganze nun zurück an den BGH und ähm der EuGH nämlich nicht äh,
Über die konkrete Abwägung dieses Interesses mit den Grundrechten der Seitenbesucher in diesem Fall etwas gesagt. Das muss nämlich jetzt der Bundesgerichtshof entscheiden.
Und ähm Breyer hat schon gesagt, na ja ähm.
Wenn der Bundesgerichtshof mir jetzt hier einen auf den Sack geht, dann gehe ich halt aus Bundesverfassungsgericht. Weil er eine klare Absage an die Vorratsdatenspeicherung von IP-Adressen.
Herbeiführen möchte.
Also Patrick Breyer ist äh mit dem Urteil nicht zufrieden.
Nein, äh Patrick Breyer ist also ich meine, der ist seit der ist da seit weiß ich nicht wie viel Jahren an genau diesen Themen dran, ne? Also überall wo irgendwie gerade so IP-Adressen gespeichert werden. Ich,
den auch eher als AK Vorrat. Der ist da, also der ist da, der ist Jurist, der ist.
Lange unterwegs her, ja.
Ja ganz hochdekorierter ähm Kämpfer und.
Ich meine, das wird immer wieder ganz interessant, ne? An der Stelle, dass wir sozusagen einen auf der einen Seite nachvollziehbares äh sicherlich auch gut begründetes
Datenschutz, Privatsphäre, Probleme haben. Auf der anderen Seite ähm es mit technischen Realitäten zu tun haben.
Und die halt nicht von vornherein voneinander gemacht sind. Also das Netz ist ja nicht.
Datenschutz in meint äh entwickelt worden auf gar keinen Fall. Ganz im Gegenteil. Das war ja auch eher noch so ein ähm,
schöner, blühender,
Garten von frei miteinander kommunizierenden gutes wollenden Wissenschaftlern, die sich gar nichts Schöneres vorstellen könnten, als sich gegenseitig so offen zu präsentieren, wie es nur irgendwie geht,
man war auch in der ganzen Entwicklung des Netzes natürlich noch mit ganz anderen Sachen beschäftigt, nämlich dass überhaupt alles erstmal zum Laufen zu bekommen. Und jetzt muss man halt schauen,
Wie man gegebenenfalls auch die technische Infrastruktur an an solche Anforderungen anpassen kann und das mit den IP-Adressen ist halt wirklich ein schwieriges Problem, gerade weil wir uns eben auch immer
mit guten und mit schlechten Leuten zu tun haben kann und in dem Moment wo man eben eine Identifizierung benötigt um einfach ein Problem wirklich mal abzustellen. Gab jetzt einfach knifflig.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, du brauchst nun echt nicht, die sind Mist, sechs Monate oder zwei Jahre vorzuhalten. Das ist wirklich für die akute Sicherheit nicht mehr äh nicht mehr zu tragen. Insofern würde ich hoffen, ähm aber na ja,
Sascha, Sascha äh Lobo hatte eine sehr schöne äh,
sehr schöner Satz irgendwo gesagt, wir hoffen, uns wir haben uns die Welt schön gehofft. Fand ich äh fand ich ein wunderschönes Zitat. An dieser Stelle. Weiß nicht mehr genau, wo ich darüber gestolpert bin. Ähm.
Wahrscheinlich äh in dem Artikel, wo er irgendwie darüber resoniert hat, das hat das tolle neue BND-Gesetz, auch wirklich eine eine prima Idee wäre, weil's dann äh am Ende Zusammenbruch von allem führen würde,
weiß nicht, ob ich da so ganz mitgehen kann, aber na ja.
Nee, ein Pott in einem Podcast hat äh war Sascha zu Gast. Ja bei.
Bei Elementarfragen, hier Nikolas Wemar, da war er zu Gast. So, weiter geht's im Takte. Kommen wir mal zu den zu den Leuten, die keine, die gar keine IP-Adresse mehr haben.
Ja, also ähm Hollio, jetzt mal ehrlich. Also wisse,
haben angerufen und gesagt, so geht das nicht. Ja und wir kommen da jetzt mal echt in die Bredouille und das war einfach mal gar nicht gut und äh verstehst du? Also ich meine, wir sind doch noch Freunde, oder?
Rudi war Sanchez. Ähm veröffentlicht ja nun wirklich mit mit,
Mit Engagement und Verf äh seit längerer Zeit allerlei äh Leaks über die äh DNC, über die Demokraten und Halloween Clinton und heute jetzt auch für Bill Clinton. Also der sitzt ähm,
Der sitzt da in Ecuador in der Ecuador oreanischen Botschaft in London und hat nun wirklich einen einen massiven Kampf gegen Hillary Clinton, den er da führt. Ja, ähm, er würde natürlich und das muss man auch sagen, so, ähm,
Das ist ja auch sein gutes Recht. Ähm als äh Journalist diese Daten zu veröffentlichen und ähm es ist auch sein gutes Recht, im Zweifelsfall
eher für Donald Trump zu sein als für Hillary Clinton. Es wäre auch vielleicht damit zu erklären, dass die russischen Hacker den ja zugeschrieben wird, dass sie eben diese ganzen Daten geben äh eben auch nur Daten über Halloween Clinton sammeln und nicht über ähm Donald Trump.
Weil es natürlich ein Interesse an der Destabilisierung der USA haben oder zumindest ihnen das unterstellt wird.
Es gibt ja allerlei Verschwörungstheorien, Fakt ist,
Es gibt keinen Beleg dafür, woher Wiki Leaks diese Daten hat. Es gibt ein paar Theorien, es gibt ein paar Anschuldigungen, diese Anschuldigungen. Für diese gibt es keine,
belege, ja? Der Verdacht steht im Raume,
dass russische russische ähm politisch motivierte Hacker sein könnten,
Ähm und der die Überlegung steht im Raume des Wiki Leagues unter Umständen dann eben eine willfährige Majonette der deutrischen Interesses sein könnte,
Hidary Clinton zu schaden.
Kann man so sehen, kann man auch anders sehen. Tatsache ist.
Kann man auch anders sehen?
Ganze Apparat in USA ist in Aufruhr.
Tatsache ist auch, Wiki Leaks kloppt diese Sachen raus und ähm.
Argumentiert und diese Argumentation ist erstmal stichhaltig. Da ist es natürlich im öffentlichen Interesse ist über bestimmte Machenschaften eines Präsidentschaftskandidaten. Ähm,
äh äh informiert zu sein. Und den ein oder anderen Skandal über Machenschaften von Halloween Clinton, ihrem Stab und dem Demokratic National Council hat Wiki Leaks ja auch schon da veröffentlicht,
Dummerweise auch noch so ein paar andere Sachen wie ähm einige echt eher private Mails von äh Mitarbeitern, also es ist dieser klassische ähm klassische Wiki Leaks äh Attitude und gerade in dem Liegen von,
irrelevanten Daten individuell betroffener hat Wiki Leaks in letzter Zeit keine besonders guten Eindruck mehr gemacht so auch das war hier schon Thema.
Aber offenbar gab's dann wohl mal ein freundliche, freundlichen Hinweis von Ecuador und die haben gesagt, ey Julian so, das ist äh Holio, das ist jetzt echt irgendwie so, nicht mehr cool, ja?
Was du hier machst, ähm, dieser einseitige Einflussnahme über die äh auf die Election. Liegt doch mal was von Trump oder ähm.
Vielleicht wäre es auch gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn du mal irgendwie ein bisschen von diesem Internet wieder wegkommst, so, das tut dir doch nicht gut.
Also denkst du, dass er seine Entscheidung von Äquador war.
Das hat Ecuador bestätigt, das ist deren ähm.
Ja, dass sie beschlossen haben, dass äh ihn sozusagen vom Netz zu nehmen, aber der Anlass dafür.
Der den Anlass hat Ecuador benannt.
Wir haben keine Lust uns diesen äh diesen ähm dieser Einflussnahme auf die US-Election ähm,
mitschuldig zu machen,
Die Regierung von Ecuador vertritt den Grundsatz der Nichteinmischung in die Angelegenheiten anderer Länder. Mischt sich nicht in Wahlprozesse ein und unterstützt keine bestimmten Kandidaten. So, dass Ecuadorianische,
Offenministerium.
Mein Habed sagt ja.
Man habe daher äh übergangsweise den Zugang zu seinen Kommunikationssystemen in der Botschaft im Vereinigten Königreich beschnitten.
Wiki Leagues twitterte daraufhin, also der Wiki Leaks Twitter Account ist ja sowieso echt einfach richtig äh geil.
Totaler Richard Corn.
Der ist einfach nur noch witzig. Also ähm,
ja ja ähm.
Also es ist ja na ja, also das Lachen bleibt einem natürlich auch so ein bisschen im Hals stecken, weil dieser ähm,
weil der Typ halt irgendwie seit Jahren in dieser kleinen äh muffigen Bude da sitzt und ähm.
Offenbar ja sich wirklich auch von den Großen dieser Welt ähm,
verfolgt fühlt und oder verfolgt wird und ich glaube, dass ihm durchaus so ein bisschen bisschen frische Luft fehlt und und irgendwie mal der so ein bisschen Erdung oder so, er will ja doch guten Grund dazu,
Ich weiß nicht wie, wie wir durchdrehen würden unter diesem Druck, unter dem er da steht. Wenn man da mal äh ein bisschen äh zynisch und leicht schuldig drüber lacht, wie wir, dann äh kann man da durchaus,
sehr viel Cyberware Speak lesen, was ganz witzig ist. Ähm Wiki Leaks gab nämlich bekannt Studienassanges, Internetlink, Haspin Intentionaly, Sivirit, by state Party,
We have activated the apropos contingency plance. Also Wiki Leaks hat natürlich Contingency Plants für den Fall
dass es mal kein Internet mehr gibt und ich kann sagen auch ich habe Kontingentsplants, ich nenne sie halt äh Myfi, also ein LTE Router, der auch äh Internet bereitstellt. Also.
Ja den wird er wahrscheinlich auch haben oder.
Den wird er haben und es war natürlich dann auch ein großer Gag. Ähm in unseren Reihen ähm unsere Myfi-Rooter mit dem Label Apropos Continucy Plan,
zu bedrucken und sie in fern fortan nur noch als solche zu bezeichnen.
So, man kann davon, ne, also ich finde, ähm.
Ich kann es nicht gutheißen, wenn einem Menschen der Zugang zum Internet verwertet, einfach grundsätzlich. Und deswegen kann ich hier auch ähm Ecuador nicht applaudieren. Ja? Ähm,
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das äh unter Umständen dem Julian nicht schaden würde mal äh ein paar Tage ohne Internet,
zu verbringen, aber das ist eine Entscheidung, die er selber oder äh sein, sein medizinischer äh,
Beirat erfällen müsste und nicht äh die equadoreanische Botschaft oder das Equador, die Equadorianische Regierung,
geht so nicht, kannst du nicht machen.
Ja, also ich meine es ist wirklich alles so ein Drama. Ich äh finde nicht, dass die Art und Weise, wie, wie liegt's derzeit geführt wird in irgendeiner Form, einem das Gefühl gibt, dass.
Dass dann auch alles in Ordnung ist. Irgendwie. Also,
dieses permanente Reden von irgendwie jüdischen Verschwörungen, die hier irgendwie an der Macht sind, um irgendwie liegts von der Arbeit abzuhalten. Ähm.
Ja, der du der hat auf jeden Fall gerade äh.
Das das geht einfach nicht mehr.
Sollte sich das tatsächlich mal professionelle Hilfe holen, kann man alles machen so, ne? Also kann man all aber du kannst jetzt nicht, also ich finde, es ist einfach grundsätzlich eine Maßnahme, die ich nicht ähm,
Gutheißen wir alle, dem das Internet abzudrehen.
Gut, kann man so sehen, andererseits ähm wofür ist Equador angetreten Equador ist äh angetreten im politisches Asyl zu geben.
Das tun sie? Ja, wir haben ihn ja nicht aus der Botschaft geschmissen, da haben wir nur gesagt.
Wir wollen nicht äh für das äh verantwortlich gemacht werden, was du da jetzt gerade alles produzierst aus politischen oder allgemeinen äh Erwägungen. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass der Druck auf Äquador enorm ist,
Also ich habe nicht unbedingt so den Eindruck, dass sie sich das jetzt einfach komplett selber ausgedacht haben.
Hillary Clinton wird ja Hillary Clinton wird ja zitiert mit Candwa Just Ron this guy und äh es hat.
Bezug auf Assange oder.
Das hat sie zu ihr, also irgendwann im Rahmen eines Meetings gesagt, dass auch Teil dieser äh Wiki Leagues League. Ähm
Und wahrscheinlich hat Ecuador einfach Angst, auch um diese kleine Bude, die sie da haben, ne? Weil wenn da jetzt eine Drohne drauf liegt, dann ist die ganze Botschaft weg, ne? Da gab's jetzt nicht so den den Assange treffen. Ähm ohne Frage kann das sehr gut sein, dass da Einfluss genommen wurde auf Ecuador?
Ähm würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die ehemalige Außenministerin der USA und aktuell aktuelle Präsidentschaftskandidatin Kontaktmöglichkeiten,
zu zu der fröhlichen Nation von Ecuador hätte und dort äh mal kurz ähm vorstellig werden könnte, so kurze SMS so.
Es muss ein Ende haben.
Ja sie muss das ja gar nicht machen. Ich meine, dafür gibt's ja irgendwie eine demokratisch geführte äh Regierung, die derzeit noch äh alle Möglichkeiten unter ihrer Kontrolle hat und die sicherlich auch äh das äh nicht gerade ganz toll findet.
Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass so Ecuador so insgesamt sich einfach so denkt, so, also dieser.
Dieser ähm Typ, der irgendwie eine Grenze nach Mexiko bauen will, ähm der genießt bei uns nicht viel. Äh nicht viel Vertrauen. Und ähm.
Seiner Konkurrentin zu schaden, ist echt nicht in unserem Interesse.
Weißt du, dass es schon innerhalb Äquadors oder auch Lateinamerikas schon so unpopulär ist, dass er äh dass sie äh Assange unterschlupft geben, dass das schon ausreicht als äh Druckmittel? Nee, ich will sie zu dieser Position zu bringen oder also es.
Glaube nicht, dass das unpopulär ist. Ich glaube, also ich glaube, die sind schon ganz happy damit, dass sie ihn da haben. So. Aber ich glaube mit dem, dass der jetzt da in Richtung, also dass der da in seinem Handeln Trump sehr
gut zuspielt, äh scheint Ecuador nicht gefallen zu haben. Deshalb so haben sie es ja auch begründet. Also sie haben ja gesagt, wir machen das, weil.
Was sie sagen.
Was sie sagen, ja, es könnte, was, was, was ist wirklich was? Zufall? Zufall.
Meinte, was was wirklich passiert ist. Super. Das kann kein Zufall sein, unmöglich. Ja, na ja gut ähm.
Jetzt gibt's halt erstmal kein offizielles äh Netz mehr vom vom Botschaftsprovider, äh muss er halt auf andere Kanäle ausweichen.
Aktion ist nicht, die Aktion ist nicht in Ordnung.
Ja. Das mehr, ne?
Wenn du ich würde sogar weitergehen, ja? Wenn du einen Gast hast, gibst du dem, du, du lässt einen Gast doch dein, dein Internet benutzen. Was ist das denn für eine Gastfreundschaft?
Da kannst du ja direkt die Leute nicht reinlassen oder sagen, geh jetzt bitte. Ich sage, wenn du mir hier das Internet abdrehen würdest, würde ich ja, ne, wäre ja auch nicht in Ordnung.
Gut, ich hätte.
Also wenn ich dich jetzt hier vorm Sicherung, vom sicheren Tod und und und Kerker und verlies äh beschützen würde und sagen würde, aber nur wenn du hier nichts twitterst. Tod oder Internet? Ja.
Tod oder Internet?
So sieht's aus.
Okay, komm, wir äh kommen jetzt zum nächsten Thema. Eine äh ein großer, großes Thema ähm in den letzten Wochen war,
Das Botnet Miray ähm,
Und zwar folgendermaßen es gibt ja ähm Internet of Things, ne? Das ist ja jetzt die neue große Sache und Internet of Things heißt,
Alles, was es vorher schon gab, kriegt jetzt eine IP-Adresse und wird ans Netz geknotet,
Und das ist das wird dann geil. So, das heißt, du kriegst irgendwie äh ne, dein dein,
deine in dem Fall waren's jetzt Überwachungskameras, ne, Überwachungskamera kriegt jetzt halt Internet und dann kann die das an die Cloud streamen und dann kannst du dich in der Cloud einloggen, kannst irgendwie da gucken, ne? Und ähm.
Diese Geräte werden natürlich unter unter den gleichen Bedingungen wie vorher äh gebaut und vor allem natürlich unter allem durchaus akuten Fachkräftemangel,
Zweitens,
werden diese Geräte, haben diese Geräte tatsächlich auch ein ein grundsätzliches Problem. Wenn ich dir jetzt da so eine, wenn ich dir eine Videokamera verkaufe, ne, eine Webcam mit IP,
Ähm und du setzt die ein zur Überwachung, sagen wir mal eines,
Einer Fläche eines Ortes. Die Meterebene wird jetzt hier mit einer mit einer IP basierten Videokamera gefilmt, damit du äh und von unterwegs ähm gucken kannst, ob hier einer drin ist, ne? Oder eine Diebstahlmeldung hast, so. Ähm.
Und jetzt steht diese Videokamera da. Jetzt hat diese Videokamera ja irgendwie eigentlich keinen Knopf oder so, sondern nur so ein Webinterface, über das sie konfiguriert wird. Man stelle sich vor, ne, der Hersteller würde nun ein Update für diese Kamera verabreichen. Ein Security-Update,
Ähm wie macht er dich darauf aufmerksam und wie,
erzwingt er, dass dieses Update auch stattfindet. Wenn deine Videokamera nämlich einfach mal kurz ein bisschen rebootet,
dann bist du unglücklich, weil du wolltest ja überwachen damit und wenn in dem Moment gerade einer einbricht oder so, das heißt,
Update ist hart, äh, let's go Bowl, ja? Das heißt, diese Geräte haben keine vernünftigen Infrastrukturen für äh für das Depräument in der Breite von von Sicherheitsupdates erst recht, nicht automatisch.
Darüber hinaus haben sie in der Regel Preise, die äh auch jetzt das langfristige Aufrechterhalten von IT
von Security Update Infrastruktur zu einer ökonomischen Herausforderung für die Hersteller machen. Also es gi.
Ein grundsätzliches Problem ist, weil wir immer das Race to the Bottom sehen und äh die Preise einfach maximal niedrig sein müssen, um mitspielen zu können.
Genau, die Kombination, so dann haben sie, dann haben sie in der Regel sowieso, ne, die Fordpasswörter, wie Admin, Admin, das heißt, als Angreifer weiß ich nicht, siehst du, siehst du die Weboberfläche, das Gerät sagt, ich bin eine
Sicherheitskameraden hast du nicht gesehen, dreiundzwanzig zweiundvierzig und du googelst einmal Sicherheitskamera dreiundzwanzig zweiundvierzig die Foldpasswort und dann weißt du wie du da reinkommst, ja?
Oder wenn sie dann dümmer oder wenn sie dann leicht klüger sind generieren sie die
generieren sie das aus ihrer MacAdresse, aber dann knackst du einmal den den Algorithmus, der aus der MacAdresse das Admin Passwort generiert und bist dann drin oder die Make-Adresse ist das Passwort. Also,
Tausende von eben diesen klassischen Kinderkrankheiten, wo sage ich mal einen durch zwanzig Jahre Entwicklung,
gestillter Entwickler eben weiß, okay. Ähm,
so kannst du det nicht verkaufen, ähm hast du eben da.
Aufgrund des Hypes des Fachkräftemangels, der billigen Preise ähm alles in einem Gerät kombiniert und das steht dann
bei dir äh im Internet spricht aber V sechs und holt sich und nimmt von überall Verbindungen an. So, dann hat es nicht lange gedauert, bis ähm ein oder zwei finnige Personen ähm,
das automatisiert haben, sich dieser Dinge zu bemächtigen, ihnen einen kleinen äh einen kleinen Botnetz Trojaner äh drauf zu spielen und sich dann dieser Geräte zu bemächtigen.
Also sprich die ganzen Deployten, Webcams waren's nur Webcams in diese.
Waren mehrere Geräte, aber hier war auch insbesondere so ein Webcam Hersteller.
Es war es war doch irgendwas anderes, aber so es war jetzt gar nicht mal so viele unterschiedliche Produkte, sondern eben nur so ein paar extrem verbreitete und angreifbare Produkte, die dann eben zusammengefasst wurden zu,
quasi einer fernsteuerbaren Angriffsarmaler, wie man das eben von Windows Rechnern früher auch schon kannte. Nur die Windows-Rechner, na ja, einerseits gibt's da einen gewissen Upda,
Zwang und äh wurde dieser Krieg ja auch äh geführt und die Sicherheitsmiss in Teilen verbessert, aber bei diesen anderen, die weiß, es wollte niemand davor sitzt und äh Fenster wegklicken muss und ähm ja, die meisten Leute vielleicht auch gar nicht mal wüssten, wie sie dieses Update einspielen können,
Das ist ja, dass das überhaupt über das Netz automatisch geht, ist ja auch eher eine Entwicklung äh äh der jüngsten Zeit. Viele Geräte ähm dieser Art
muss der dann teilweise noch über USB an einen Windows-Computer angeschlossen werden, wo man noch eine Update-Software runterladen muss und so, das können wir ja o.
Gerät nicht Neustadt, wenn sie es in diesem Moment ne.
Furchtbar, ja, also äh und selbst das hat oft nicht funktioniert, sodass auch der Frustrationsfaktor natürlich auch extrem hoch ist und Leute einfach überhaupt gar keinen Bock haben auf so einen Scheiß.
Update über Internet, ist natürlich alles schön bequem, nicht wahr? Das Gerät kann regelmäßig selber gucken, ja, gibt's dann was Neues,
da haben sich natürlich dann auch wieder neue Sicherheitslücken aufgetan, zumal dann eben diese Update-Prozeduren auch nicht entsprechend gesichert waren. Da gab's ja dann äh hier auch aufm
Meckenden, sprechenden Fall und der McOS, ja, wo dann sozusagen diese Updates dann unautorisiert geholt wurden und sich dann eben so männende mittelmäßig dann äh die Trojaner über so ein Softwareupdate eingetan haben, sind, wenn man sozusagen ein sicheres Gerät hat, kann ein Update-Mechanismus ja sogar dazu führen, dass dann eben diese Plätze noch verbliebene Sicherheit,
auch wiederum äh umgangen wird. Es ist.
Daid, Mechanismus bauen ist wirklich schwierig, Sicherheit eines Gerätes aufrecht zu erhalten ist schwierig und ähm hier haben wir das äh hier haben wir das Problem. Vielleicht erklären wir noch ganz kurz, was ist ein Botnet, also ein Botnet.
Bezeichnet eine Herde an äh Geräten, die,
auf Kommandos warten. Also üblicherweise realisierst du das so ein bisschen so mit
relativ einfache Software auf deinem infizierten Gerät, die zum Beispiel in irgend so einem IHC-Kanalwahl auf Befehle wartet oder so, ne? Dass du halt irgendwie sagst, okay,
Wenn der und der Nutzer signiert diesen und jenen Befehl gibt, dann führen den alle aus. Ja, und dadurch kannst du halt Befehle auf,
Tausenden von diesen Geräten gleichzeitig oder natürlich auch,
Auf jedem Gerät einzeln ähm ausführen. Und ähm genutzt wird sowas in der Regel für Aufgaben, wo eine Paralisierung ähm notwendig,
oder förderlich ist.
Zum Beispiel der ähm Versand von Spam-Nachrichten ist, was was du auf verschiedene Mailadressen parallelisieren möchtest, damit nicht,
eine äh damit nicht eine IP-Adresse oder eine Mail Adresse auffällt, sondern jeder nur eine E-Mail-Adresse äh eine ist per Mail verschickt oder wenige,
wenige zehn oder wenige hundert.
Ähm und was du auch natürlich äh verteilen möchtest und parallelisieren möchtest, sind die Nile of Serviceangriffe, die Nil of Service heißt, du überflutest einen Server mit,
Anfragen und zwar mit so vielen bis dieser irgendwann nicht mehr reagieren kann und diese Spot Netz aus IOT Devices.
Wurde vor einigen Wochen eben dazu benutzt, ähm,
zum zum Beispiel das Blog von Brian Craps, einem sehr bekannten IT-Security Journalisten Platz zu machen. Das ging dann so weit, dass ähm,
der Hochverfügbarkeitsanbieter AK Mai, auf dem dieses Blog gehostet war, ähm mit diesem Dinil of Serviceangriff nicht mehr klar kam,
und ähm gesagt hat, okay, wir haben zwar dieses Blog hier ähm Probodo gehostet, aber wir ähm.
Denen das jetzt.
Wir nehmen das mal äh zurück, ja? Wir äh kündigen diese freiwillige äh,
Diese freiwillige Dienstleistung an diesem Journalisten, da hat sich Ackermai nicht so einen großen Gefallen mitgetan, weil da eine Kugel gesagt hat, na ja okay, dann machen wir das halt. Wir haben hier noch so ein paar Giga Gigabit über. Ähm,
Das war natürlich so ein kleiner PR-Film für AKAMAI, aber was wir jetzt machen. Das Krasse war, dass dieser Dinal auf Serviceangriff auf bei Bryan Crabs. Der stärkste in der Geschichte des Internets bis dahin gemessene war. Ähm,
kurz darauf äh überschlugen sich dann die Rekorde und ähm der Betreiber dieses Botnetzes hat dann.
Oder es tauchte ein ein Post,
In einem Forum auf der Betreiber dieses Boardnetz, dann sagte ach ähm na ja, das mit diesem Dedos ist irgendwie zu krass so. Das ist ein scheiß Business, weil äh du verdienst eigentlich relativ wenig Geld, äh kriegst hohe Strafen und jetzt sind die, nachdem ich das jetzt so,
Presse war äh sind eh die ganzen Strafverfolgungsbehörden da hinterher. Insofern ähm dampfe ich mal meinen Source Code hier für die Öffentlichkeit.
Da sollen sich andere die Finger dran schmutzig machen. Es dauerte natürlich auch nicht lange, bis andere sagten, oh geil, ich kann hier einen Bot net erstellen, mit dem ich einfach mal kurz ähm.
Oh, super.
Sehr viel platt machen kann und das passierte dann auch. Es gab dann einen Dinal of Serviceangriff auf ähm,
dünn, äh den Betreiber von äh DNS-Dienstleistungen,
Und betroffen waren dann Twitter, Amazon, Spotify, Netflix, das PlayStation Network. Am Freitag war einfach der größere Teil des nordamerikanischen äh Internet äh irgendwie mal platt.
Und jetzt wurde natürlich auch wieder Spekula spekuliert. Ähm wer war das, ne? Und USA sagten natürlich klar, Russen,
Also ganz ganz klarer Fall, die Russen wollen hier unsere Wahlen beeinflussen.
Brian Crabs schilderte Erpressungsschreiben, wo dann irgendwelche Bitcoins verlangt wurden
und auch Julian Ashorge meldete sich zu Wort mit der äh mit dem Aufruf
Mister Essangestill a Life and Wiki Leaks ist Publishing. We ars supporters, two stop taking the use Internet down
Ähm,
Also mit anderen Worten Julian Assange wusste natürlich auch, es kann kein Zufall sein, dass er kein Internet hat und ganz Nordamerika auch nicht. Es war natürlich Wiki-League-Supporter. Ähm,
die das getan haben. Womit ganz klar ist, wo hier der Wind wieder weht.
Überhaupt, was raucht der.
Ich weiß es.
Es ist echt nicht zu fassen.
Auf jeden Fall zum heutigen Zeitpunkt gibt's wieder mal keine sinnvollen Belege dafür oder keine Glaub an Belege dafür, wer das jetzt war?
Verschiedene Theorien, wie immer bei einem Cyberangriff, weil ein Cyberangriff eben auch so schwer zu attribuieren ist. Scheiße, jetzt sage ich auch schon Cyber-Angriff, ja,
Ähm interessante Debatten, die jetzt entstehen.
Das Cyber macht dich auch schon ganz wuschig.
Ich bin schon ganz gesibert hier. Ähm der der Interessante Debatten jetzt natürlich entstehen ist.
Wer ist schuld, ja? Also diese es stellen sich bei diesen Angriffen auf Infrastruktur, die hier in Ausmaß erreichen, was nicht zu tolerieren ist, ne? Wir müssen was gegen tun.
Fragen wie und was man dagegen tut. Ja, es gibt ja zum Beispiel Möglichkeiten ähm wenn diese Geräte noch die ähm die sich die initialen Sicherheitslücken haben.
Dann könntest du sie darüber übernehmen. Du könntest also quasi jetzt die Sicherheitslücken der Geräte nutzen, nicht um ein Bodnet darauf zu installieren, sondern um das andere Bot net runterzuwerfen und die Geräte zu patchen.
Du könntest, du könntest den den oder die Command Control-Server, es gibt mehrere Hacken.
Und sie nutzen, um diese Geräte zu patchen, weil du denen ja jeden Befehl geben kannst. Kannst sagen, patche dich selber, lade dieses Sicherheits-Update runter und mache ein Reboot. Geht alles. Du bist ja äh unter Kontrolle dieses Gerätes. Ähm.
Die Frage wäre nur, wer macht das und mit welcher rechtlichen Grundlage? Also es wird natürlich diskutiert, ob das FBI jetzt einfach mal dieses Botnetz nimmt und der platt macht. Es gab auch Fälle in der Vergangenheit, wo größere Botnetze einfach von Forschern gekapert,
platt gemacht wurden, ja, wo man einfach gesagt hat, alles klar, äh wir denstallieren die Botsoftware und äh finden das entsprechende Sicherheitsupdate ein. Oder teilweise sind sie auch gar keine Sicherheits-Updates, sondern klassische Trojaner, die irgendeiner,
man sich irgendwo so nebenbei klickt, ja? Ähm.
Wobei diese Geheimdienste sich natürlich über solche äh Bodnetzer auch freuen. Da waren immer mal gebrauchen.
Kann man immer mal gebrauchen, so.
Also Cyberattacken machen möchte.
Genau, das ist natürlich der Punkt, wenn jetzt das Event ausgerechnet das FBI, dass er den Vertrauen aller genießt, äh sagt wir, äh, können wir, wir wir nehmen das Spot mit mal für uns, dann ist das alles gut. Dann hast du halt die Geräte im Schrank stehen bei den Leut.
Jetzt gerade aufs FBI.
Weil dieser Vorschlag vom FBI diskut.
Ach so, naja okay, gut, aber ob die jetzt die Kompetenz dafür haben, da bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher.
Steht es.
Irgendeine andere drei Buchstaben Organisation ihrer Wahl.
Im Moment kannst du dir dieses diesen Bot net Scheiß runterladen, ne? Du könntest auch einfach dir eine eigenes bauen und die scheiß Kommanden Control-Server von diesen Leuten platt machen. Die Frage ist nur, darfst oder machst du das? Äh und natürlich hätte.
Für alle jetzt so, ne?
Natürlich hättest du das Problem der Juristiktion. Also erstmal müsst ihr's überlegen, darfst du das überhaupt? Ich würde fast sagen, wenn,
dass wenn du wirklich,
Akute Ausfälle, größere Ausfälle des Internets hast, dann ist es im Interesse aller, dass dieses Board net verschwindet. Ähm die die Besitzer dieser Geräte wissen da ja in der Regel noch nicht mal was von.
Insofern könnte man tatsächlich von einer Dienstleistung an den Kunden und an dem Internet selber sprechen, wenn jetzt hier einer hingeht, dieses Bot-Netz Carport platt mach.
Ähm man könnte sich aber auch zum Beispiel darüber Gedanken machen, äh wie man mit diesem Hersteller umgeht,
Ja, du setzt da so einen scheiß so scheiß Kameras in die Welt und auf einmal machen die das halbe Internet kaputt. Ähm kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen, na ja, kann mal passieren. Da kann man doch dann tatsächlich mal von Produkthaftung reden,
ist übrigens eine Forderung, ich hab das heute Morgen nochmal nachgeschlagen, die schon zweimal in Gutachten für den Chaos-Computerclub ähm gestellt habe, bin ich auch nicht der erste gewesen, aber,
ich eben auch. Ähm einmal zwanzig, vierzehn im Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda, einmal zwanzig fünfzehn im Innenausschuss, da beim ersten Mal war's
einfach generell IT-Sicherheit beim zweiten Mal was IT-Sicherheitsgesetz konkret.
Und auf vielen anderen Bühnen fordern viele äh Experten eine Produkthaftung äh für, wenn genau so eine Scheiße passiert. Damit nämlich Hersteller von vorne herein ähm,
Motiviert sind, sich über die Sicherheit dieser Geräte Gedanken zu machen. Hm,
Und jetzt gibt's eben die Diskussion, wie kriegt man diese, wie kriegt man diese Situation in den Griff und aufgrund der strukturellen Probleme, die dazu geführt haben, wird es eben auch noch länger dauern,
bis man das im Griff hat, weil wenn jetzt gerade die einen Geräte gehackt werden, wird es nicht lange dauern, bis es die nächsten sind,
Und es wird auch nicht lange dauern bis der nächste Scheiß auf dem Markt,
worüber immer wieder diskutiert wurde, war der Gedanke hier gut, aber dann hackt einer die Kamera, was will er mit meinen Bildern? Dann hackt einer in den Kühlschrank, was will er mit der Temperatur in meinem Haus machen? Da hakt einer meinen Heizungstermostat.
Ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen.
Ja, ne, weil da hat einer mehr Heizungsthermostat, was machen wir damit? Ähm,
Das Risiko für den Individualnutzer ist außerdem, dass diese Geräte natürlich dann das erste Gerät in deinem Netzwerk sind, was geohnt wurde, ja?
Du sitzt irgendwie fleißig da und hast äh äh updatest den ganzen Tag, dein dein Android-Telefon und dein Windows-Rechner und dein Drucker und dann nochmal deinen Drucker, weil dann doch wieder die, die ähm.
Diese Digital Rights äh Sperre von von,
wieder weghaben willst und dann dann steht da irgendwie so eine komische Kamera filmt dich dabei und Dos in in Ruhe irgendwie das nordamerikanische Internet kaputt. Und als nächstes heckt sie irgendwie deinen Drucker, ne,
Aber nicht so gut.
Da ist beim Kamera sind natürlich, da muss man jetzt nicht lange drüber nachdenken, sich noch ein paar andere Bedrohungsszenarien mal zu schauen, wenn man sozusagen Kameras einsetzt, um die eigene Sicherheit zu verbessern und dann äh werden sie von anderen Leuten benutzt, um einem zuzuschauen.
Hier nochmal hier nochmal ein wichtiger Nachtrag ähm als es hier um diese äh Natpots Kameras ging. Ne, wo alle immer gedacht haben, diese Kameras wurden gehackt ähm
um die scheiß Rechenzentren zu filmen. Da weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das der letzten Sendung vernünftig gesagt habe, also totaler Unsinn, davon auszugehen, dass diese Kameras gehackt wurden, weil sie Videokameras haben. Diese Kameras wurden gehackt, weil sie,
Für die Atmens sind, zu der Kontrolle dienen und deswegen natürlich in das Adminetz kommen. Und wenn sie da sind,
Im Zweifelsfall mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht ordentlich gefirewallt werden,
Und deswegen hast du ein großes Interesse, diese Kameras zu hacken, weil du dann einen Fuß
Managementplan hast, also in dem Netz, wo die ganzen SSH-Zugänge sind, wo das ganze Monitoring ist, wo die quasi von hinten,
An ihre Webserver oder was auch immer für Server herankommen, die ins Internet natürlich hoffentlich nicht die kritischen Dienste überhaupt exposen. Deswegen ist es so interessant, diese diese Geräte zu zu vertreiben und als NSA zu backtoren. Aber das nur am Rande.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall interessante Spekulationen, wer dahinter steckt, wir werden dieses Problem im Zweifelsfall noch ein paar Mal haben und es gibt jetzt eben auch
De Maiziere hat das heute dann gesagt. Äh die Frage, ob man da nicht mal die ähm
Hersteller in die Produkthaftung nehmen sollte. Das ist sehr schön. Jetzt darf nur niemand dem Messer sagen, äh dem Messer sagen, dass wir als DCC das schon seit Jahren vorschlagen, weil er macht das nachher doch nicht,
Aber wenn er das macht, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich das Erste, was ich jemals äh in in einem Ausschuss des Deutschen Bundestags gefordert habe, was dann am Ende auch irgendwie eine Form von äh Realisierung erfahren hat. Insofern stehe ich hier und fiebere mit.
Das Linus Neumann Gesetz, genau, Produkthaftung, ich meine, ich gehe da voll mit.
OT-Gesetz. Linus Internetaustrinks.
Genau, wer Lust hat, sich ein bisschen darüber äh äh lustig zu machen über diese ganze Bewegung, dem empfehle ich mal wieder einen Twitter-Account.
Die Internet-Offshit.
Genau, Internet auf Shit ist äh äh sehr unterhaltsam,
Ich hatte ja schon diesen Webcam-Huck äh Account letztes Mal schon äh genannt,
Ja, also ich meine ist wirklich dramatisch und die unglaubliche Zunahme an solchen Connected Devices, die lässt nichts Gutes hoffen für die nahe Zukunft. Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig,
Anlass für diese Unternehmen in irgendeiner Form ihren Pfad zu ändern und in gewisser Hinsicht wäre eben tatsächlich diese Einbeziehung der Schäden ähm.
Ein Faktor, ne? Muss man natürlich jetzt auch sehen, wer hat da Beweispflicht, was ist sozusagen äh
heißt das, dass jetzt jeder Softwarefehler potentiell äh so ein Unternehmen ruinieren kann, weil er auf der Basis dieser Glas Action,
Rools, die es ja schon gibt in USA, wir haben das ja hier in Europa, in der Form leider nicht, es gibt hier so Sammelklagen, aber es gibt halt nicht diese Möglichkeit zu sagen, okay, ich äh fühle mich jetzt hier,
einer gewissen Schadensgruppe geschädigter ähm zugehörig und deswegen legen wir mal alle unsere Klagen zusammen. Das sind ja schon durchaus Sachen, die eben sehr, sehr, sehr teuer werden können. Und wenn jetzt alle
ohne dieser Webcam, um die es da ging und diesen DVR, diesen digitalen Biorecorder sich da entsprechend zusammentun, können sie das zumindest in USA, ich glaube, ein paar anderen Ländern
auch schon ganz schön weh tun. Das ist ja auch im Wesentlichen eine Firma, die hier betroffen ist, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe, diese Shion Mai.
Äh kann, kann sein, ja.
Ja, ja, also so ein chinesisches Unternehmen.
Aber davon davon kannst du eigentlich abstrahieren. Das Entscheidende ist, dass du ein chinesisches Unternehmen ist, dann kannst du den ja mal mit deiner Produkthaftung kommen. Dann sagen die auch so, äh muss.
Ja, aber dafür gibt's auch dann bald so hier internationale Freihandelsab.
Ja war doch nicht mit China.
Na ja, irgendwann schon. Die wollen ja jetzt erstmal äh TTIP und CETA durchsetzen, damit sie sozusagen China dann ihre äh Regeln auf äh drängen können.
Also es gibt ja noch, es gibt dann ja, ich will es gibt natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, dass jetzt diese Skiang irgendwie äh Rückrufaktion starten oder sowas. Wir werden sehen, wie sie diesen Spaß in Griff kriegen.
Ja gut, Rückrufaktionen bedeutet ja meistens auch,
An wen, ne? Also es gibt dann auch kein kein klares äh Kundenherstellerverhältnis, weil das läuft dann alles über irgendwelche Händler, die über irgendwelche Versender, an irgendwelche Leute irgendwas geschickt hat, Registrierung und ein klares äh Update-Verhältnis gibt's an der Stelle nicht, wenn die Geräte das halt nicht machen. Die Leute schauen sicherlich selber nicht auf diesen
teilweise nicht existenten Webseiten nach beziehungsweise selbst wenn der Hersteller jetzt wollte, äh könnte er kaum äh in Verbindung geraten, zumal man davon ausgehen kann, dass er all diese ganzen betroffenen Geräte mittlerweile alle so äh ihre Softwareupdate-Funktionalität auch wiederum verloren haben und ähm
gar nicht mehr so ohne Weiteres zurückzuholen sind. Ein Drama.
Es wird spannend bleiben. So, jetzt kommen wir aber nochmal zu äh heute ist echt was los, was ist.
Na ja, man muss da einiges zusammenfegen. Also. Botnet to go für jedermann.
Internet auf Sportnetz. Ähm die EU Copyright Reform steht an,
und ähm wir haben da ja glaube ich bei der LMP einhundertfünfzig mit unserem geschätzten Gast Julia Reder äh auch drüber gesprochen, was da so alles ansteht. Und jetzt ist aber der,
der Vorschlag da und man kann nur mit dem Kopf schütteln. Wir haben das ja auch schon mal angesprochen,
Das Leistungsschutzrecht in Deutschland eine Erfolgsgeschichte, eine absolute Erfolgsgeschichte. Für Google,
die damit eingeschränkt werden sollten. Es war ja eben innerhalb kürzester Zeit soweit, dass alle,
Verlagshäuser, Sofortdeals mit Google hatten, dass sie alle Leistungsschutzrechtansprüche abtreten, auf das sie weiter verlinkt würden. Wir erinnern uns, wie
Öttinger dann sagte, nee, das geht so nicht, wir müssen jetzt hier, wenn sie uns als kleine, wenn wir mit achtzig Millionen kommen, dann kommen wir jetzt halt mit mit einer Viertel Milliarde zurück oder mit wie viel ähm Einwohnern ähm.
Die EU hat und er sagt, jetzt pass auf, wir machen, wir wir werden die Probleme des des Leistungsschutzrechtes in Deutschland,
eindeutig ausmerzen und zwar in Deutschland gilt das Leistungsschutzrecht ein Jahr. Das heißt nach einem Jahr wird davon ausgegangen, dass die,
Der Kleinstausschnitt oder der Titel des Artikels seinen Newswert verloren hat,
Und deswegen ähm ihn dann auch kostenfrei verlinken darfst. Äh in der EU würde man das gerne zwanzig Jahre machen
Jetzt hat sie eine heiße Katze kein Geschichtsbücher mehr schreiben, ne? Also ist tatsächlich so, ne? Äh ähm und außerdem ähm sollen auch auch kleinste Ausschnitte
Kleinste Ausschnitte.
Ähm äh Unterrichtsleistungsschutzrecht fallen. In Deutschland gab's ja noch diese Ausnahme, dass man sagt so kleinster Textausschnitt geht schon klar. Und ähm hm.
Julia sagt, also selbst eine Privatperson, ja, die einen Link zu einem Nachrichtenartikel mit einem kurzen Auszug aus dem Text oder mit einem Bild,
oder mit dem Titel dieses Dings postet, könnte dann da drunter fallen.
Unsere Shownotes.
Genau, oh Scheiße! Ja, unsere Shownotes. Ja. Gibt keine Shownotes mehr. So, ist vorbei.
Ist nicht mit Titeln.
Zumindest nicht in der EU. Wir müssen jetzt dann halt was weiß ich, in China.
Nicht hinschreiben. Die Links heißen einfach nur noch eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Wir müssen Logbuch Netzpolitik demnächst in China auf einer Webcam hosten.
Das wird schön.
Ähm genau, wir wissen demnächst in China auf einer Webcam hosten,
ähm weil wir sonst eben unters EU-Leistungsschutzrecht fallen. Oder du müsstest dann eben den Inhalt des Artikels paraphysieren, ja? Also Welt,
fremd, wie nur was. Ähm Julia sagt dann auch im Interview, kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Google anders reagieren würde, als damit,
Die Gesamtzeitungsartikel unauffindbar zu machen. Na ja,
oder eben wieder eine Ausnahmeregelung zu machen, dass nur äh den Kleinen damit geschadet wird, ähm die ja jetzt gerade richtig übel unter dem äh unter dem Leistungsschutzrecht ähm leiden. Ähm weiterhin.
Soll es dann die Verpflichtung von Plattformen, bei denen es Nutzeruploads gibt, also ähm äh nutzergenerierte Inhalte, Beispiele wären also jetzt klassisch, werden jetzt Soundcloud, YouTube, ähm,
Vimeo oder was auch immer, wo also ein Nutzer potenziell.
Rechte verletzende Inhalte erstmal hochladen könnte, ne? Also ein Lied ähm ein Video oder ganz schlimm, du Copy Pase ist ein Presseartikel auf Pace bin.
Ist die Hölle los, ja? Die müssen alle verpflichtet sein,
mit den eigentlichen Recht, Rechte-Inhabern Deals einzugehen, ähm wie es eben auch bei YouTube ja schon möglich ist, ne? Die haben ja dann irgendwann gesagt, okay, bei euch ist es das rechte Verletzungsding, so,
soweit verbreitet, dass wir euch direkten ähm, dass wir direkt den.
Direkten Zugang haben wollen. Wir wollen quasi ein Interface haben, wo wir Inhalte sofort selber löschen können, die uns nicht gefallen,
Das ist ja die Lösung, die letztendlich YouTube Put dann äh angeboten hat. Noch dazu verbunden mit einer Automatisierung, ne? Also wenn ein Inhalt einmal
nicht akzeptabel war, dann erkennen die wieder Uploads des selbigen ähm oder du hast oder nehmen dann glaube ich die,
Dinger daraus, die die Musik aus dem Video oder so, das soll verpflichtend werden. Das heißt, du wirst dann auch nicht mehr in der Lage äh hm also ein, so ein, so ein Dienst, so einen Dienst überhaupt anzubieten, ne. Also da auch da eine Zentralisierung.
Äh die da ähm.
Be ähm betrieben wird, die einfach nur noch davon ausgeht, dass es ganz viele zentrale Richteranbieter gibt. Und genau,
Arsch will ja ähm Oettinger auch retten. Deswegen rennt er ja auch auf deren ähm,
Auf deren Veranstaltung rum und versucht in animiert die ähm Verlage im Prinzip Einfluss auf ihre Redaktionen zu nehmen. Also das ist wirklich schauderhaft, was da geschieht,
Und wir können froh sein, dass wir da eine ähm Allianz,
haben die sich ähm die sich dagegen wendet,
äh von EU-Abgeordneten, die da richtig schon so aktivistisch, ja? Die haben dann so ein YouTube-Video, wo sie sagen, ey, hier geht's, ey, hier ist gerade echt die Kacke am Dampfen und wir müssen dagegen stimmen, dafür brauchen wir eure Unterstützung. Ähm das ist wirklich,
Unglaublich was ähm was.
Was der Öttinger da für ein für einen Schaden auch ähm anstellt. Ja und.
Die gesamte Kommission, ja.
Ja das geht ja auch einher mit der äh mit dieser ganzen Content ID äh Technologie,
die auch so ein bisschen als selbstverständlich dann äh vorausgesetzt wird, dass man sowas eben irgendwie mal so eben aufbauen, betreiben äh kann. Ist natürlich ein bisschen absurd ist, weil.
An der Stelle haben wir es einfach auch wieder mit so einem Grundproblem des Urheberrechts zu tun. Es ähm,
Weiß gar nicht, ob wir das hier auch schon mal so thematisiert haben, dass man ja ähm.
Im Prinzip alles erstmal urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Ab seiner Veröffentlichung oder ab ab seiner
zu Zugänglichkeitsmachung. Also ich schaffe irgendetwas und alles, was ich schaffe, da muss ich jetzt nichts weiter draufschreiben. Ich muss es nicht in irgendeiner Form registrieren, sondern das hat dann einfach erstmal Urheberrecht. So und äh,
wenn ich ich muss muss sozusagen nichts dafür tun. Wäre es anders war ich mal anders.
Wenn wir sozial ein System hätten, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt habe ich hier etwas, was urheberrechtlich geschützt ist. Aber ich muss es erstmal registrieren,
muss man dafür eine ID holen und ich muss das sozusagen beim Staat explizit als hier mein Werk habe ich jetzt mal angemeldet, gib mal eine Nummer
die eindeutig ist, damit es damit ich das hereinschreiben kann, dass man darüber eben auch diese Informationen holen kann. Wenn dem so wäre, wäre das ja eine ganz andere Voraussetzung. Erstens könnte man eben auch,
grundsätzlich eine äh immer sofort überprüfen, ist etwas urheberrechtlich geschützt,
oder nicht. Man kann es auch belegen, man kann auch sofort ähm anderen Leuten die Möglichkeit geben, das zu überprüfen,
Und ähm dann gäbe es eben diese Datenbasis. Die gibt's halt derzeit einfach nicht bei YouTube ähm sammeln die sich im Prinzip so ein System äh zusammen von beteiligten Unternehmen und das sind natürlich alle die, die sich so einen Aufwand auch nur erstmal leisten können,
und die man halt dann äh auch ab bis der Arzt kommt.
Und man hat sozusagen überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit, wenn man jetzt auf der äh zwölf Jahren Netzpolitik heißt das so, zwölf Jahre.
NP
MP, also der ich weiß nicht, wie lange du das Ding noch unter Geburtstagsparty laufen willst, aber das war ja mal der Anlass, damit überhaupt zu starten. Ähm hatten ja letztes Mal dann auch gesagt
Das findet nochmal auf diese Veranstaltung hinweisen wollten, wenn die Videos verfügbar sind, wie das denn verfügbar gab's äh in dem Zusammenhang zwei,
Vorträge mich einerseits eben von,
Julia Rieder, die diese ganzen Wahnsinn mit der Urheberrechtsreform auch nochmal schön dargestellt hat und dann gab's noch einen zweiten Talk, der eben ähm gerade ist, auch diesen Vorstoß der EU-Kommission für eine Content-ID-Pflicht
alle Plattformen auch nochmal genau auseinandergenommen hat, das war dann leider der letzte, den ich dann auch nur noch zur Hälfte mitbekomme, bevor ich leider die Veranstaltung verlassen musste
Jetzt haben wir allerdings die Links auf die Videos in den Shownotes mit dabei. Tja, das ist ein Drama,
und ähm ich wundere mich auch so ein bisschen, wie sehr sich,
die Verlage der Einspannen lassen und auch wunder ich mich auch, warum sie eigentlich immer noch glauben, dass das alles so eine gute Idee ist, zumal ja der Widerstand aus den Online-Redaktionen,
stark zu sein scheint.
Die betroffen werden, ja.
Die stark betroffen werden, wo er einfach auch die Reaktionen einfach auch wissen, dass es sich einfach äh äh anders verhält als hier die ganze Zeit behauptet wird, weil die Grundannahme ist ja an dieser Stelle einfach falsch. Die Grundeinnahme ist
Google verdient Geld oder Googles mal das Beispiel, ja? Aber so derjenige der die Kunden zu mir schickt verdient ja Geld mit mir,
Ich meine, Amazon bezahlt Leute dafür, dass auf sie gelingt wird,
Ja, also das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Aber Amazon bekommt man über einen Affiliate-Link Geld dafür, dass man die zu dieser Plattform schickt.
In Deutschland soll das dann ausgerechnet für Zeitungsartikel anders herumlaufen, das ist doch vollkommen absurd.
Also nicht nicht nur, dass das Leistungsschutzrecht einfach ein,
äh das einfach die ganze Prämisse hier einfach schon mal falsch ist. Wenn überhaupt müsste man sich äh eben über anders herumlaufende Modelle Gedanken machen.
Es ist.
Das wäre doch schön, wenn wir hier noch Affiliate-Link auf auf äh Zeitungsseite hätten.
Ja, äh der, der ist.
Für ihre Abos? Warum nicht?
Es ist lassen wir das.
Genau, aber ich empfehle sehr den äh Vortrag von Julia dazu zu sehen. Sie hat ja dann auch nochmal so einen Aktivisten ähm Kampagne gestartet unter dem Namen safe the Link,
Genau. Denn das und das finde ich eine ganz schöne Verdichtung an der Stelle, dass sie das klar macht, dass ähm es hier schlicht und ergreifend um den Link geht,
Es geht hier sozusagen um um die Essenz des äh des Webs, weil wenn man nicht mehr frei linken kann, dann ist einfach mal der Spaß vorbei im Web.
Katast, also ist wirklich in in Ausmaß nicht mehr ermesslich, was das für ein Stuss ist. Das ist auch wirklich nur noch Stuss.
Ja und man man merkt auch dem Öttinger leider an, dass er sich einfach hier in einem äh schickungsfreien äh Raum bewegt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nein, nein, nein, ich bin da wirklich inzwischen nicht.
Ich ich glaube, also wenn man das mal zu Ende denkt, ne.
Und da kann ich wirklich immer noch auf äh Tim Ruhe the the Master switch hier verlinken, Helfer verweisen. Jetzt verlinke ich hier auch schon verlinke ich äh darf ich ja nicht mehr. Ähm.
Wenn du ernsthaft den Akt des Verlinkens mit hohem Risiko behaftest, ja? Dann,
Und das Internet wird ja weiter bestehen, dann schaffst du,
das, was große Konzerne ohnehin seit jeher haben wollen. Tim Wuh beschreibt dieses Internet ja im Prinzip auch so also eine anfangs konnte da jeder rein, jeder machen was er wollte. Jeder hatte seine Chance, da gab es dann auch Wettbewerb, ja.
Und irgendwann wird einer fett genug, Monopol genug, marktbeherrschende Stellung genug, ähm dass er im Prinzip den ganzen Mister ähm alleine laufen lassen kann. Und selbst ein Facebook,
hätte kein Problem damit, wenn jetzt der Link verboten wird,
dann sagen wir wunderbar, wir wollten eh alle Inhalte bei uns haben und dann können die, ähm, können die können die Pressevertreter ihre direkt bei uns veröffentlichen,
ja? Ähm es gibt wenig Lobby dafür, dass es ein frei verlinkbares Internet gibt,
So, die größeren Anbieter, die gerade Milliarden mit diesem Ding machen, kommen größtenteils auch ohne zurecht. Man kann sich jetzt nochmal überlegen, wie das bei, wie das bei Google läuft, ne? Ich habe das ja auch schon öfter mal hier angesprochen. Google,
lebt davon, dass es ein chaotisches und unstrukturiertes Veb gibt, in dem man eine Suchmaschine braucht,
war das die einzige die einzige,
wirkliche Einnahmequelle für die ist, Werbung in den Suchergebnissen, alles andere äh ist nicht in der Lage, diese Milliarden zu generieren, die sie haben. Facebook äh hätte gerne, dass äh das Internet, das Zugangsnetz für Facebook ist.
Alle Inhalte, die es gibt, mögen doch bitte bei Facebook sein. Ähm, insofern kann man da sagen, dass Google sicherlich nochmal ein starkes Interesse daran hat, dass der Link erhältlich bleibt. Ich werde dann auch mal fragen, äh ob Google nicht ähm,
da mal äh seine Lobbyistenkraft ähm für nutzen möchte, werden sie ohnehin schon längst machen, aber ähm.
So Netflix funktioniert ohne Links. Apple Music funktioniert ohne Links. So, das ist unter Umständen.
Er ein zu erwartender Kollateralschaden. Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass es dass dieses, dass dies dass eine solche gesetzliche Maßnahme irgendwann auf einmal äh an der harten Realität ernsthaft scheitern würde
und ich glaube auch, dass es genug Leute gibt, die sagen, ach, wenn dieses Internet jetzt am Ende mal manifestiert.
Dass dieser verfluchte Markt uns gehört und da jetzt nicht irgendwelche neuen Konkurrenten auf einmal reinkommen und dann auf einmal verlinkt werden oder sowas, ja
Ähm dann haben wir da nicht unbedingt was gegen.
Also da solltet ihr euch auf jeden Fall ein bisschen mit beschäftigen. Das ist glaube ich etwas ähm was noch sehr viel Ärger machen kann.
Vor allem wir brauchen Links.
Ja eben wir brauchen link.
Wir brauchen links,
Ja, wir sind als erstes dran. Wir stehen da, wenn die äh wenn das Leistungs wenn das Leistungsschutzrecht kommt, stehen wir als erstes an der Wand, weil wir die ganze Zeit diese ähm diese Artikel verlinken
bei uns in den in den Shownotes. Wir sind als erstes dran Tim.
Genau und dann gibt's kein Lokbuchnetzpolitik mehr.
Oder ihr findet's nicht. Nee, erst einmal.
Was habt ihr jetzt davon? Jetzt haben wir natürlich ein starkes Argument geliefert für den Widerstand, ne? Ab morgen brennen die Mülltonnen.
So, jetzt kommen wir zu den, jetzt kommen wir ehrlich zu den Kurzmeldungen. Also eine Kurzmeldung darf ich nicht, ähm darf ich einfach nicht,
außen vor lassen. Ähm mir sind ja echt die Schuppen. Also mir ist ja wirklich aus dem Gesicht gefallen. Als ich diese Nachricht gemeldet habe. Ähm ich äh gelesen habe.
Schuppen aus den Haaren.
Schuppen ist viel mehr wie die Augen aus den Schuppen, ja? Der äh und zwar gibt es jetzt einen Milliardenprogramm für WLAN und Computer in Schulen.
Johanna Wanka, Bildungsministerin möchte gerne im Rahmen des Digitalpakts.
In allen vierzigtausend Schulen des Bundes bis zweitausendeinundzwanzig ähm Computer und WLAN haben. Ich erinnere mich.
Als ich so in den neunziger Jahren zur Schule gegangen bin, ja,
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau in welcher Klasse ich da war. Neunziger Jahre.
Der was gab's da.
Da gab es ein Projekt namens Schulen ans Netz. Und ich erinnere mich an viele Schulen.
In Westdeutschland.
In West, ja, weiß ich nicht, ob ich bin Westdeutschland, ja. Ähm dass viele Schulen da massiv ausgerollt wurden mit Computerräumen, mit Internetzugängen. Mein erster Teilabzugang mit einem äh Mode,
war über eine eine örtliche Nummer einer Schule.
Und ähm ich habe mit Unternehmen dann als als Schüler zusammengearbeitet, hab Schulen vernetzt. Ja, ich habe,
Mit der Schlagbohrmaschine die Löcher gebohrt, Kabel reingeworfen und so, ne? Cut drei oder sogar Cat vier Kamera oder was weiß ich, was es damals gab. Vielleicht war das auch schon Cut fünf,
und haben da äh irgendwelche Urei, also wir haben auf jeden Fall diese Infrastrukturen gebaut und wir haben Schulen ans Netz gemacht und es gab dieses Projekt. Und ähm,
Ich weiß auch, dass ich damals an unserer Schule schon randaliert habe, weil die kein Internet hatte.
Und dann hat die irgendwann Internet bekommen. Wenn ich heute lese, dass es offenbar irgendwo Schulen gibt, die kein Internet haben.
Dass wir einen Investitionsrückstau von fünf Milliarden Euro haben, den wir bis zwanzig einundzwanzig.
Bis dahin bin ich in Rente, wenn alles nach Plan läuft, ja? Wenn alles nach Plan läuft. Ähm.
Hast du irgendein Business von dem ich noch nichts weiß? Nein. Ich plane eins zu haben. Ach so, so. Okay.
Ich plane eins zu haben. So, ne? Und ähm wenn ich das lese, da fällt mir wirklich alles aus dem Gesicht,
die Schulen heute noch nicht ordnungsgemäß vernetzt sind. Eine Schule hat einen Grund,
dass wir das überhaupt haben, ja? Ich weiß einmal, damit man die Kinder für ein paar Tage,
los wird am Tag. Ähm andererseits auch, dass man die zu irgendwelch irgendwie halbwegs brauchbaren Mitgliedern der Gesellschaft erziehen kann und vor allem um sie vorzubereiten auf das.
Was irgendwie die Gesellschaft, die sie einmal gestalten und prägen werden, die sie einmal ausmachen werden. Von ihnen verlangen wird.
Deswegen bin ich da in dieser ganzen Bildungspolitik so
immer so wirklich emotional, dass ich seit sage so Bildung muss allen zur Verfügung stehen, Bildung muss nach vorne gerichtet sein, wir wollen in dieser Zukunft nochmal leben, die muss für diesen Menschen gestaltet werden, alles alles in die Bildung.
Auf diesen Vorschlag von Johanna Wanke, auf dieser Ankündigung von Johanna Wanker.
Meldet sich dann Josef Kraus, der Präsident des deutschen Lehrerverbandes, der immerhin,
Einhundertsechzigtausend Lehrer an weiterführenden Schulen vertritt, ne? Wir reden hier nicht von der Grundschule, wir reden hier von äh Gesamthauptrealschule und Gymnasium,
Sagt er, ich möchte keine Laptop-Klassen. Die Schulen seien doch ohnehin schon digital unterwegs. Mehr braucht es nicht,
Bei den Schülern würde durch mehr Digitalisierung die Neigung zum Häppchenwissen nur noch gesteigert. Besser wäre es, das Geld in die Schulbibliotheken zu stecken, findet Kraus, ähm,
gerade sozial schwache Schüler müssen lesen, lesen, lesen und zwar das gedruckte Wort. Dieser Mann vertritt einhundertsechzigtausend Lehrer, die in deren,
Schoß wird das Wohl der der kommenden Generationen gelecht haben. Ich weiß nicht wie viele
wie viele Regale, der mit fünf Milliarden Euro kaufen möchte, denn Bücher kriegst du heute schon hinterhergeworfen, weil sie keine haben will,
Weil sie so ich meine die Leute versuchen mal einen Bücherregal loszuwerden. Da kannst du aber äh,
wenn hier, wenn hier in Berlin ist ja Klassiker, ne? Irgendwelche Leute stellen ja ihren Müll auf die Straße raus, kleben dran zu verschenken, ne? Völlig normal.
Ganz ganz klar machen wir so, dann pissen die Hunde dran und am Ende irgendwann tritt sich das fest, ne? Und ähm wenn da wenn da Bücher drin sind, meinst du, die nimmt noch einer raus.
So, ihr seht so ein zwanzig Jahre altes Buch. Et des interessierten Toten.
Und dieser Typ meint, bis die Leute, die jetzt gerade auf der weiterführenden Schule sind. Das heißt, sie sind irgendwo zwischen elf und fünfundzwanzig Jahre alt, je nachdem wie viele Ehrenrunden die da drehen, ne? Die sollen jetzt Bücher lesen oder was?
Haltet sie brust von diesem Internet fern.
Vor allem sowas.
Weil weil die ja als Bücherleser nachher angestellt werden, weißt du? Die werden.
Ich würde ja nicht grundsätzlich sagen, dass es ein Fehler ist, ein Buch zu lesen, von daher äh alles okay, nur die Annahme, dass das jetzt sozusagen durch eine Digitalisierung automatisch wegfallen würde, ist natürlich auch äh Quatsch.
Ich war als Kind beim Orthopäden, weil ich so einen scheiß schweren Turnister hatte, den ich da jeden Tag zur Schule schleppen musste. Und jetzt sollen die Bücher drucken. Ich wäre heilfroh gewesen, wenn ich so einen Kindle gehabt hätte,
Oder irgendwas, weißt du? Äh Katastrophe. Es ist eine Katastrophe,
So, wenn ihr liebe nachfolgende Generationen, sagt nicht, wir hätten es nicht gewusst, lasst euch nicht erzählen, wir hätten hier, wir hätten nicht gewusst, äh äh wie Josef Kraus äh eure Bildung äh äh ruinieren wollte,
steht auf, schnappt ihn euch. Noch seid ihr jung und straffrei. Das fällt alles noch unter Jugendrecht. Das ist unglaublich.
Bei Lager der Nation hat Philipp Banzer ähm von ein paar Interviews berichtet und ist auch, weil er schon äh älteren Sohn hatten, dass wir in dem Thema auch ähm bisschen stärker äh drin,
und äh völlig interessant, dass er,
auch von den Schulen, die ähm schon früher an solchen Pilotprojekten teilgenommen haben und die eben wirklich mal auch äh durch digitalisierte äh Klassen hatten, dass die eigentlich,
auch ganz andere Erfahrungen gemacht haben, als jetzt hier unterstellt wird. Das zum Beispiel sich dadurch auch das Lernen ähm,
dahingehend ändert, dass eben die Lehrer auch sehr viel mehr in diesem Lernprozess mit einbezogen werden. Dass die Lehrer halt auch einfach sagen, ja ich muss nicht unbedingt immer da vorne stehen,
und ähm alles Wissen und sozusagen auch diese unanfechbare Gottheit sein, die alles vermitteln und alles, was ich nicht weiß, dass das darf auch nicht gewusst werden, weil das weiß ich ja selber nicht
Ja? Äh dass man sich eben an der Stelle einfach auch zurücknimmt oder einfach auch sehr viel mehr in so ein Team,
arbeiten eigentlich äh übergeht. Das wäre etwas, was durch Rechnereinsatz ähm befördert wird.
Das war, was übrigens auch eine ganz andere Wissenskultur dann eben ist, ne? Also ähm ich meine zu, es wäre tatsächlich,
bei zur Zeit eine CD nicht zur Schule gegangen bin, war das immer äh ein besonderer Genuss, aber der wurde auch äh
Übel geahndet, äh wenn man was besser wusste, als der äh als die lehrende Person, ne? Also wenn du da irgendwie sagtest, so, nee, ist falsch. Ähm das hast du teuer bezahlt,
weiß ich, ich will ja besser wissen, ne? Und das konnte ich, ich konnte da ja nicht sitzen, wenn irgendjemand was falsches sagt und ähm das habe ich äh mitunter äh teuer bezahlt. Ähm diese Kultur äh zu ändern, ähm,
es wäre ein ein Schritt, der wirklich so viele,
Bereichernde Folgen für eine Gesellschaft hätte, ja? Ähm wenn eben die Autorität des Lehrers sich nicht mehr äh nur da auf dem Wissen stützt,
und auch ein durch Nichtwissen dann eben nicht mehr angegriffen wird, sondern durch einen informierten, interessierten Lernvorgang pflegst, ja? Was daraus
oder eben nicht so ein autoritäres Diktieren. Äh was daraus für Produktivität entstehen könnte, für eine Gesellschaft, die diese Zusammenarbeit dann eben auch in den Unternehmen
weiterlebt, ja? Die und so im Sinne des Fortschritts der Entwicklung arbeitet, das ist nicht abzusehen, das wäre der Wahnsinn.
An der Stelle muss man aber auch nochmal ein bisschen Kritik äh äh äußern jetzt auch an dieser ähm Initiative von der Johanna Banka, äh denn wenn ich's richtig verstanden habe, ist diese Initiative im Wesentlichen wirklich eine Bereitstellung von Gerät und Netz.
Lehrer und und an die Lehrer dann, genau, dann ja, das ist recht, das.
Weil man muss ja nun auch mal dafür sorgen, dass eben äh den Lehrern auch äh diese neuen Konzepte auch näher gebracht werden, ne? Weil das ist ja nun im normalen Lehralltag äh nicht so ohne Weiteres ähm,
ähm leistbar
Ja, ich meine, auch die Lehrer sind unter Druck, das ist ja äh gar keine Frage, die haben ihre Dienstpläne zu erfüllen, die haben ihre Anwesenheiten äh in den äh in den Schulen und müssen äh vor und nachbearbeiten
dieses Ideal von irgendwie der Lehrer äh kann ja dann im Urlaub die Füße hochlegen und so weiter. Das ist ja alles Quatsch, das weiß jeder. Darum geht's auch gar nicht,
Aber äh diese Kompetenzen müssen natürlich auch näher gebracht werden und dazu muss natürlich auch ein Umdenken gefördert werden. Und das ist soweit ich das bisher wahrgenommen habe, nicht unbedingt Teil dieses Programms.
Das ist richtig, das ist nicht Teil dieses Programms, das kommt aber auch vom Bund und ähm das.
Bildung ist Ländersache.
Bildung ist Ländersache, deswegen sagt sie ganz klar, wir stellen diese Infrastruktur bereit,
warten, müssen sie die Länder und die digitale Bildung realisieren, indem sie didaktische Konzepte erarbeiten und Lehrpersonal ausbilden.
Ja, also kritisieren kann man hier einfach noch den Mangel an äh koordinierten,
Vorgehen der des Bundes und der Länder insofern äh eine schöne Vorlage des Bundes, wo man halt jetzt erwarnt erwarten würde, dass eben dann auch die anderen mitziehen. Aber man sieht eben.
Dieser Lehrerverband zeigt ja, auf welchen Boden das fallen wird.
Lehrerverband, ja, ja, genau. Genau und das, das ist halt wirklich äh das Problem. Ich erinnere das auch gerade wieder an so eine äh auch so eine Autoritätsmoment, den ich gerade im im Zug hatte, wo ich mal wieder ein Online-Ticket nicht ausgedruckt hatte.
Mehr wie vom.
Das geht aber doch inzwischen mit dieser DB NAF App oder was.
Ja, was ich in dem Moment nicht wusste, ist, dass man in dieser Handy-App einfach seine Online-Tickets reinladen kann. Man macht er.
Schnack und dann kommen die.
Schnack und dann kommen die. Wusste ich in dem Moment nicht.
Habe ich dir jetzt gesagt.
Ja, hat hat mir schon jemand anderes gesagt.
Jetzt klau, klug.
Weiß ich jetzt, du bist hier eh der Klügste, aber ich tracke zumindest hier meine Dummheit auch offen zuschaue und trage so Unterhaltung bei.
Ja, der der Bahncut einhundert Fahrer.
Nee, aber die Argumente, ja, der Zugchef äh hat mir aber dann sozusagen die, ja, aber da steht ja drauf, dass das jetzt nur gilt, wenn wenn es irgendwie ausgedruckt ist und man sieht, warum.
Und das ist so 'ne Frage auf die er so nicht vorbereitet war und rummelte irgendwas von na ja dann dann,
dann ist das hier auf meinen Computer registriert. Weißt du, wie soll etwas, aber mein Computer registriert sein, indem ich's ausdrucke,
Ja äh ist so. Ja, ich könnte es ja auch dreißig Mal ausdrucken. Was wäre dann? Also was was soll sich an der Situation bessern, wenn er sein,
scheiß Barcode von meinem Papier scannt, anstatt von meinem Bildschirm. Es ist wirklich.
Das heißt, der Typ ist mit dem, der ist mit dem Kontrollieren dieser Tickets betraut und weiß nicht, das heißt, also wenn der, wenn er ernsthaft nicht weiß, wie der, wie der Fälschungsschutz dieser Tickets funktioniert.
Kontrollierte ja am laufenden Band BahnCards Personalausweise und EC-Karten ohne zu wissen warum.
Also ich meine, aber warum steht es halt auch da drauf? Also warum steht es auf diesen Tickets drauf, dass sich die ausdrucken wollen.
Also das äh.
Das, das ist darauf wollte ich hinaus, ja? Also man man befindet, man befindet sich hier immer noch in so einem äh luftleeren Raum manchmal, wo einfach keiner äh weiß mit Digitalien klarzukommen,
Es frustriert mich.
Gut, aber jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen abweichen, also ähm ich wollte nur ganz kurz ähm zur gleichen Zeit, wo eben die,
Johanna Wanka eine solche Initiative zeigt ähm sagt die Kultusministerin Susanne Eisenmann von der CDU zuständig für Baden-Württemberg,
Ach ja also im Schuljahr zwanzig siebzehn zwanzig achtzehn Informatik als Pflichtfach in Klasse sieben anzubieten.
Das wird wohl nichts. Das müssen wir auf Eis legen.
Was? Ja. Ja, also.
Baden-Württemberg hatte für das Schuljahr zwanzig siebzehn zwanzig achtzehn das Pflichtfach Informatik ab zwei Klasse sieben vorgesehen. Ähm
Ebenfalls hatten sie vorgesehen äh einen Ausbau der Ganztagsschulen äh sowie äh Initiativen zur besseren Einbindung ähm behinderter Schüler ähm,
Und aus Lehrermangel müsste diese Pläne jetzt leider auf Eis legen.
Also es gibt nicht genug ausgebildete äh Lehrer, die Informatikunterricht liefern können und deswegen gibt's halt.
Letztes Vergangen, Ende des vergangenen Jahres haben sie gesagt, okay, wir machen das jetzt mal. Äh Pflichtfachinformatik bei den Basiskurs, Medienbildung, ab äh ab das fünf Pflichtfachinformatik ab Klasse sieben. Ähm.
Mit einer Stunde pro Woche, ja? Klassenstufen acht bis zehn, das neue äh Fachinformatikmathematik Physik. Ähm,
in denen halt dann irgendwie so,
die Zusammenarbeit von, ne, den von den Dreien auch behandelt werden soll. Schöne Idee war im MP3 Algorithmus, ne? Du hast Physik, Schallwellen, du hast Mathematik äh Abbildung von.
Äh von von Schallwellen und Kompressionen und damit dann eben auch die Informatik, wie du äh die Informationen komprimierst und aufrecht erhältst. Tolle Idee. Tolle Idee.
Aber findet nicht statt. Wegen keine Le.
Fällt aus, wegen ist nicht. Ähm das geforderte Plus von fünfhundert Stellen hat der grün-schwarze Haushaltsausschuss nicht genehmigt. Oh, das war jetzt ein ein Leistungsschutzrechtverstoß von Heise DE. Aber das ist die Welt, in der wir leben.
Auch ein auch die Welt, in der wir leben, ist ja diese vielfach kritisierte ähm.
Politik, die ein Ziel vorgibt und das dann gezielt nicht erreicht. Ähm insbesondere kritisiert wurde das ja bei dem Gesetz gegen Abmahnabzocke,
Wo damals schon gesagt wurde, dass,
wird nicht funktionieren. Dieses Gesetz gegen Abmahnabzocke beschränkte den Streitwert für Tauschbursen, Abmahnungen eigentlich auf eintausend Euro,
ja? Also was eine Abmahnung, dann musst du halt Streitwert angeben und da wurde gesagt, bei einer Fightsharing-Abmahnung nur tausend Euro,
Streitwert.
Daraus, dann gibt's ja den Gebührenkatalog, der Anwaltsgebühren daraus ergeben sich laut Katalog nicht mehr als hundertvierundzwanzig Euro Anwaltsgebühren.
Nein, damit wäre erfolgreich dieser ganze Kram äh äh in ein, sage ich mal, weniger,
ruinösen Preisbereich gedrückt worden. Allerdings hat das Gesetz eine Ausnahme,
Die damals schon vom Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband ähm kritisiert wurde, denn wenn der Streit fährt,
Nach den besonderen Umständen des Einfelds Einzelfalls unbillig ist, dann gilt diese Deckelung nicht,
Und es gab aber keine gesetzliche Klarstellung darüber, was jetzt unbillig ist. Ähm.
Ist das überhaupt ein Recht, das wieder so ein so ein so ein Rechtstherm, oder? Unbillig. Also nicht im Sinne von nicht, nicht äh bezieht sich aber schon jetzt auf den Wert. Ja, ja.
Nee, nee, unbillig heißt, nicht zulässig, glaube ich. Also, warte mal. Äh unbillig im im rechtlichen Rahmen heißt, jetzt.
Entschuldigung, dass ich immer nachfrage.
Billig, also es ist nicht auf den Preis bezogen, sondern auf die Billigkeit und Billigkeit ist einem deutschen Recht vorkommender, unbestimmter Rechtsbegriff, unter dem eine gerechte und angemessene Anwendung allgemeiner gesetzliche Bestimmung
verstanden wird. Das heißt unbillig ist im Prinzip auch unangemessen, ja?
So, wenn der unbillig ist, dann geht diese Deckelung nicht. Und jetzt haben sie ähm.
In fünfunddreißig Prozent der untersuchten zweieinhalbtausend Fälle,
wurde auf die Unbilligkeitsregelung Bezug genommen und mehr als eintausend Euro Streitwert angesetzt.
So, das heißt, die Abmahnkanzleien machen genau das. Und das hatten sie auch angekündigt,
Das war ja offen. Das haben sie angekündigt, ich habe gesagt, nö, ne, super. Super, das ist ja nicht unbillig und ähm in in das im im Moment eine Drittelchance, dass dein Abmahnanwalt sagt äh ja hier Unbilligkeit, haste nicht gesehen. Meine Abmahnung wird nicht unbillig.
Ja.
Die wird unbillig, meine Abmahnung wird unbillig.
Oh Mann ey.
Ja. So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. So ja.
Oh, oh, hallo. Hallo, Ende der Sendung.
Hallo Ende der Sendung. Jetzt haben wir schon zwei Stunden. Zwei Stunden. Ja.
Haben wir schon fast fast zwei Stunden voll gequatscht ja sehr schön. Na ja dickes Paket hier nochmal zum Jubiläum. Möchtest du jetzt noch Blumenfarben von mir oder so.
Nö, du kennst ja meine Amazon-Wunschliste, aber nix, nix.
Tja. Nachdem du dich jetzt beklagt hast, äh stoppe ich natürlich die Lieferung, die ich schon längst im.
Ja, das ist.
Gesetzt habe, ne?
Ähm ich wollte noch bekannt geben, dass äh am siebten elften, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Der Vorverkauf für den dreiunddreißig C drei in die öffentliche Phase gehen wird, ja? Da gibt's also dann, ich suche mal den genauen Zeitraum raus,
Der siebte elfte zwanzig Uhr, da wird der erste, die erste Phase des freien Vorverkaufs gehen
dann nochmal am neunzehnten elften, das ist ein Samstag um fünfzehn Uhr und dann nochmal am fünfundzwanzigsten elften um zehn Uhr.
Ähm alle diese Zeiten in der äh UTC plus eins Europe Berlin
CET Zeitzone. Ähm da könnt ihr also ähm,
Zu diesen drei Zeiten, die jeweils bereitgestellten Kontingente erstehen, das lohnt sich also, die mal im Kalender zu markieren, um das sicher zu gehen, dass man da ähm nicht nachher das Nachsehen hat.
Also das sind die äh drei Vorverkaufsphasen für den dreiunddreißig. C drei äh auf die man achten sollte.
Gut, jetzt Reizer war. Äh vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Nächste Woche sehen wir uns in Berlin und kommt zahlreich äh wir sagen tschüs.
Ciao ciao.